good
all right good morning everybody
today is thursday
i have to look at my paper to know what
day it really is january 20th this is
the new hampshire house election law
committee we have public hearings
scheduled for today starting at 9 30 and
somewhere somebody's clock has at 9 30
so i am declaring it time to open our
session
and before we begin our legislative
business i ask that you rise and join me
in a pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
thank you everyone the first bill we
have scheduled for public hearing this
morning is hb 1567 this is relative to
the removal of election officials from
office 1567
the
prime sponsor is with us here today to
introduce us to introduce the bill uh
welcome representative allegra thank you
good morning committee members and madam
chair thank you for giving me the time
to present this
this proposal
um
again my name is mark allegro i'm a
representative from grafton's seventh
district
this bill
is about election integrity
that's a term bandied about a lot these
days and i know that the first response
from a lot of people is to roll their
eyes but
it's a serious problem not only here in
new hampshire but around the country
just by way of a couple of quick
examples in arizona the maricopa county
audit of the 2020 election
uncovered scores of thousands of
double votes votes by dead people
votes by people living in other counties
and so on in
wisconsin
um the court just ruled
the use of ballot harvesting boxes
as illegal
um and we'll see how that plays out in
the long run but these things contribute
to concerns about
whether our votes are being the right
way they especially contribute to
concerns about chain of custody matters
so in new hampshire we have our own
issues like every state
and this bill attempts to mitigate just
one of them
and that is
willful negligence of local elections
officials i'm not implying that this is
a
rampant issue
but it's an issue that exists
this is not a bill bent on punishing
local election officials
this is just a bill that will provide
citizens with recourse
in the face of willful negligence on the
occasions when it does arise
so i'm going to start with just a couple
of examples really just one and then a
description of what
pushed me
to actually uh propose this legislation
this is and i'm not going to mention
names i'm not even going to mention the
names of towns
um
except in the one case because it's been
in the newspapers numerous times so it's
it's no secret and that non-secret is
the bedford
election fiasco
where it was discovered that close to
200 ballots
were found missing after the election
and then yet a second batch
was found in september from the 2020
election was found in september 21
uh during the execution of a special
election there
um the secretary of state if i'm to
believe the um
to newspapers which is difficult these
days uh the secretary of state stated
that they've seen this kind of thing
before so it's not a one-off
sometimes mistakes happen
but sometimes there's willful negligence
associated with those
errors shall we say
in this case
the hundreds of ballots that were
missing were kept secret from the public
for over a year
i don't know if you've read this in the
newspapers but could you imagine that
ballots were misplaced they were
discovered in the
underneath
in one case
a box
underneath the voting machine
and this was kept secret from the public
and from town officials
for over a year
alright
the local elections officials whose
names i won't mention
uh at meetings with town officials
said we did the right thing by keeping
this secret
we lost votes
we kept it secret now some of them were
counted in the second batch i forget
whether it was the first or the second
batch one of these batches of votes was
not even counted
not even added in the tally we did the
right thing in keeping it secret uh they
stated
and then
with what can only be described as
serious hutzpah if you'll excuse the
expression
they stated we report i'm paraphrasing
here we report to the no this is a quote
we report to the secretary of state
not the town council
oh my goodness
i can never imagine
a statement like that coming out of my
mouth we serve the people
and we report to the people now i've
witnessed other infractions in my time
being involved in elections some of them
in this state
some not another some have been as
simple
and difficult to deal with is like in
the past year
um when poll observers were kept over 40
feet from observing ballot tally
it's a difficult situation that's easy
to understand but there's no excuse for
not letting these poll observers
do the other things that are in protocol
we usually follow such as come in in the
morning check the voting machine see
that it's zeroed
and check it at various times during the
day and at the end of the day
i've seen poll wardens
um
actually
uh what was the term that was used
correcting ballots
correcting ballots making sure that the
bubbles were filled in all the way
there's not an election official that
doesn't know that that's a no-no
i'm very sorry
i've seen
poll workers
prompting
voters
uh with their street address
everybody knows you you're to come in
you're to tell them your address
and then they say what's your name i've
seen people come into polling places
not remembering yeah you heard me right
not remembering their street address
okay
and the poll worker prompting them
prompting them this is a no-no
i i've witnessed a bunch of other
infractions but there was one in
particular that was relatively recent
that inspired me to draft this
legislation uh with my co-sponsor
representative silver
and that was in an election that took
place it was a special election in 2021
um again i'm not going to mention the
town or the candidates i
um i went there just as a volunteer to
hold signs
and uh out came a voter
and you probably haven't heard about
this one
it was actually i think obscene
i heard a voter
come out and say i just filled out my
ballot i went to fill out my ballot
and i noticed that the bubble for the
other candidate was already filled in
so
to make a long story short uh someone
who had standing to actually inquire
went in and inquired of this election
official how did this happen was this
one
or was this many who knows you know if
this happens 10 times that's 10
disallowed votes when the ballots are
counted and in these town elections 10
votes can be a lot as we all know
and this was the explanation uh from the
election official
i'm gonna paraphrase this person he said
well we were running out of ballots and
so i ran over to the other polling site
and i grabbed a handful of ballots
and i came back with them and apparently
this spoiled ballot was amongst them
so it's my fault
well i got home and i discussed this
with an acquaintance who served as a
pole warden
and when she heard it and i knew this
was wrong
but she knew the details and was
incensed what are the problems with this
explanation
well first of all
a paul warden or king george himself
cannot just go to another polling site
and
quote unquote grab a handful of ballots
this is a no-no okay
anybody who works in the polls
certainly with any regularity
understands that ballots come
in sealed packages
and if you have to
[Music]
transport ballots
there's a reporting process and you
don't just grab a handful of ballots off
the desk
so
you know that's question number one how
did this election official
do that
the second question is how did a spoil
ballot wind up in a stack of
presumably unspoiled ballots
because spoil ballots are supposed to be
marked clearly and put in a separate
envelope and kept clear of those other
ballots
so there were at least two matters here
that amounted not to just a goof up but
perhaps
unacceptable negligence
so here's the problem
the problem is that voters have almost
zero recourse
to deal with these matters
okay election officials make mistakes
like everybody else but they also do
things out of laziness and out of
willful negligence
you know the rules
in some cases
appear to serve them when they need to
give people instructions about stepping
back
you know you can't wear that in the
polling site and so on and so forth but
when it comes to actually following
clear-cut rules like chain of custody
and access to ballot for poll observers
and matters like that
a lot of times the rules are just
ignored
so the voting public has no recourse and
that's what this bill seeks to provide
there are no punitive measures
but this allows
poll observers when voting officials
break protocol
and it leads to significant errors
it allows recourse for voters to take
the matter to court to file
and
uh
if found negligent that
local official can be removed from
office
yes i know
this might create a hardship because
these are not exactly the most popular
positions
you know this isn't like movie star
everybody wants to be one
but
again we have to put the horse before
the card
we have a serious concern about voting
integrity in this state and around the
country
and when
errors like this are being tolerated
with no recourse
it does not contribute to our confidence
in the outcome of elections presently
voters feel
hurted disrespected
ignored
no wonder there's so little confidence
in our electoral system and this isn't
everybody in this room also understands
it's not a partisan issue this has been
going on for quite some time
so
the new hampshire house of
representatives
we
this institution of which i'm a part
we have it in our power to help rectify
the situation not only do we have it in
our power but by constitution we have
the duty to rectify this kind of
situation
and um
we have the ability
to restore confidence
in our elections
i scratch my head and i wonder how could
we not take an opportunity to mitigate
these problems as they arise and try to
come to solutions
that help restore this confidence that's
so desperately needed
i'll take that opportunity to end any
prepared statement i have to make and
i'd be happy to answer
any questions and
i would just urge you to please
don't be polite when questioning me i my
whole career has been answering
questions at the lab bench and in the
classroom i enjoy questions and i look
forward to addressing yours as directly
as i may thank you thank you
representative questions from committee
members
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
questions
did you report any of these infractions
to the secretary of state that you had
witnessed well some of them have been
reported in the one case i mentioned
about filling in bubbles
completely that was reported to the town
clerk
um
i know that this one in bedford was
reported to the secretary of state and
yes um again i'm not going to mention
town but some of these
breaks in protocol i'll call them were
reported to the secretary of state's
office
but you know how it is on election day
the secretary of state must get
goodness knows how many phone calls
and
in my experience anyway they rarely get
back to the person who's phoned in with
the complaint so yes
the ones i've spoken about here today
they've all been reported to
you know the next the next highest
authority
but there was
never any action taken on any of them
although the bedford
situation i understand is being
investigated by the attorney general but
we'll see how that turns out okay thank
you
representative hamer allset
any other questions from committee
members representative groin
in the
last sentence of of your added wording
lines 12 and 13 you say
in any such court proceeding if the
court finds that removal is warranted
the prevailing registered voter shall be
entitled to an award of reasonable
attorneys fees and court costs um
it does not indicate who would
compensate the person for those
court costs or fees are you anticipating
that it would be the
the defendant or that the town or the
state or
who would compensate for those attorneys
fees and court costs yeah thank you for
pointing that out i noticed that myself
this was primarily drafted by
representative silber who's an attorney
and
i agree with you i think that's an
oversight
and i can have that attended to
fairly rapidly
and so that that proper wording is in
here
my expectation is that those court costs
would have to be uh covered by
the the defendant in this case
but
i i don't know fully how the judicial
system works
it it needs to be compensated by someone
because otherwise you're asking
you know mr smith and
thornton
to cover perhaps thousands of dollars
worth of
legal costs and that would be a um
a real
impediment to
to them actually
reporting and following through on these
kinds of infractions
thank you i'll see to that
and i will get back to you
uh within 48 hours
thank you and follow up madam chair
follow up
um
in that same vein
if the
you know
i think we recognize that there is
potential for
um
politicizing this
uh if somebody is just upset and doesn't
like the way things are sure
they can make things miserable for
election officials
um
if there is a suit and the suit fails
should there be compensation for the
court costs of the election worker in
the same way well if
a case has no merit of course the court
can dismiss it uh immediately
and that solves part of your problem
um
no there is not a mechanism
um and that's true in i would think the
vast majority of
of civil suits
so um
i'd be happy to hear a suggestion
but again if you have people that
see something that they think is wrong
uh it's a deterrent
for them to report it
um
so
we can i'll i'll be sure to address that
with my co-sponsor on this um
and get back to you within 48 hours okay
thank you
thank you further questions from the
committee representative i apologize we
have a sub and i have not written down
your last name representative
representative pimentel
thank you and i can't find it on my
email which i just look for so we will
take care of that and thank you for
being with us today
go ahead thank you madam chairman and uh
thank you rep uh allegro
uh
there's
from what i understand there is a chain
of command on
the election site
being the
moderator and
the the town clerk
and then of course the secretary of
state
rather than
have a
law
writing in
avenues for litigation
wouldn't it be more prudent to
write a law requiring some kind of
chain
of command
and
chain of
information being passed
as far as any kind of those infractions
um if i'm not understanding your
question let me know but if i it seems
to me that you want to incorporate into
this
a prepared chain of command
and the purpose being that the um
whoever is responsible for committing
the infraction should be the one
identified to that i would have to
answer that um infractions can be
committed at all levels and ultimately
yes um the person at the top of that
chain of command is responsible but
again this isn't a matter of um
punishing people for innocent
uh errors so if if a purposeful
infraction is committed by
um i don't say a town clerk and the town
moderator doesn't know about it uh until
later
um
the chain of command i think is you know
it's not the
town moderator that would be the subject
of possible removal it would be the town
clerk
or whatever the the lower on the chain
of command is then did i answer your
question or
sort of gonna have a follow-up so
um
so if this litigation this uh
basically litigation bill
is not meant to
be
punitive um
i i don't understand why
having some sort of
written
uh
receipt of an infraction
being passed up that chain of command
so that they can be
looked at by
the moderator by the the town clerk
and if needed the
secretary of state
as opposed to just saying hey this guy
did something
and
you know it's not
it's not really you know like i'll take
care of it
uh might not work for for reasons you
can see yourself yes now i think i
understand your question
um
so your question is is can we not deal
with this
by allowing uh superiors in the chain of
command to deal with the infraction
before it gets to a court and
i have to agree that's another good uh
idea that we can incorporate into this
bill by an amendment um
i think it's very rational idea uh and
potentially save costs
and saves the unfortunate reality that
it's going to
you know potentially create
more cases for our judicial system to
handle thank you
thank you
further questions from committee members
i have a couple
um
representative um just on the bill
mechanics is the intent
that
the registered voter may be bring suit
as to
an official in their community or any
community because i'm not sure i see
that restriction
well i think it
so in other words i am a registered
voter in
goffstown could i bring suit if this
bill was to become law could i bring
suit in
uh bedford for the
what you've just talked about today
because
it talks about it says to remove any and
then the list
or other town or city official but it
doesn't say of the registered voters
community
the intent is not for anybody in the
state to bring
uh the matter to the courts
for any other jurisdiction the intent is
for the matter to be brought
from within the jurisdiction
okay
and further question is do you have any
idea what the average length of time to
resolve an equity matter in the superior
court is
uh no i i don't um and i appreciate that
might be a better question for
representative silber yeah
you know
every bill has uh improvements that can
be made but
this is a case where i think we have
more than the starting material
uh required to mitigate an otherwise
unaddressable issue
um i mean you see all these these people
that are
committing infractions of standard
protocol and in some cases law
and
they're there for the next election so
if it takes time to go through court
you know that's a weakness of our court
system of our judicial system
but
these people could remain in office
committing the same
pardon the term screw-ups
at infinitum
the way things stand
so
i think it's a
vast improvement to have a mechanism for
the public to have some recourse
thank you
um finally my last question at this time
and i just note that we have a bill for
sort of a similar purpose coming up
after this so i'm not as concerned about
the start time
um
you the bill refers to
a knowing
refers to someone knowingly failing to
perform a duty
you talked about willful negligence and
at another time said unacceptable
negligence what is
the standard that
you all were trying to set when this
bill was drafted
knowing infraction
um so intentional is that what you mean
uh no that doesn't mean intentional
intentional
is with forethought
okay
so for instance
a person can make a mistake
that's
not intentional
but then the failure to correct that
mistake or perhaps even compound it
um
that is
knowing that's willful
um we're parsing words now on this uh
an election official knows
an election official knows that they're
not supposed to go to another polling
site and grab a fist full of of ballots
okay
you know of course the
the finding has to be in favor of the
plaintiff so
you know the the uh
the responsibility here lies with the
plaintiff
but again
here's an example where a um
an election official
understands knows has been practicing is
trained
that they're not allowed to just go to
another polling site and grab a fistful
of bills i mean a fistful of ballots
um
and so that is
that's a negligence
you do know representative that you can
transfer ballots under certain
procedures from polling places yes
yes that's right and had that election
official follow those procedures it
wouldn't have been an issue and had that
election official follow those
procedures
he wouldn't have somehow managed to
scoop up
one or more spoiled ballots we'll never
know how many
okay thank you further questions from
the committee members
i'm not seeing any thank you thank you
for your time
also signed up to speak on 1567 is
christina gilford
welcome miss guilford
good morning members of the committee
um christina gilford a dairy town and
school moderator
um
i i appreciated a lot of your questions
on this bill
i i
i completely understand
that voters want to have recourse
for people that may not be aware the
town moderator is the top election
official on election day
so
the buck stops there
people that i hire like assistant
moderators it's my job to train them
it's to it's my job to make sure they do
things the way they're supposed to
and if they don't it's my job to correct
the issue
and to make sure i don't hire them again
[Music]
this bill as written
is
has assistant moderators in here has
deputies in here those people are
appointed and hired they don't put their
name on a ballot and put themselves out
there and open themselves up to this
um i'm
my term is ending in march i already put
my name in to run again
i understand that i have to answer to
the voters of derry
that's who elects me
that's who i answer to and i'm
responsible for anyone that i hire
the way this bill is written it's going
to be next to impossible to hire people
i've already had assistant moderators
reach out to me
and tell me if this is how it's going to
be i'm not gonna work anymore
because we have voters come in and ask
questions
and a lot of it is because of what they
hear in the news
and they wonder
is the machine plugged into the internet
um is there a watermark on the ballot is
there this
you know all these questions about
things happen in other states and we
don't do things the same way in new
hampshire
i do take the time i speak to those
voters they reach out to me online i
speak with them i meet with them
i talk to them and a lot of times when i
explain this is the law this is how it
works this is what we do
they
definitely understand
what happened in bedford
you know we all heard about it on the
news
i honestly
i don't understand and if something like
that had happened in derry i would
resign
that it's just me because that is you
know counting the ballots making sure
they're all accounted for that's the job
of the moderator
um
that but that's me i know not everyone's
the same
but
you know the moderator runs the polling
place we have a two-year term
we can be replaced in two years
um i know there's another bill coming up
about recall and about three-year terms
well maybe it needs to be expanded and
allow
all election officials to be recalled if
that's the case
but um
you're talking about
volunteers people who didn't put their
names on ballots suddenly being taken to
court
um
maybe having to pay fees
and you know you have the voter being
reimbursed
if
the voter
you know doesn't you know wins but if
that vol you know relative volunteer i
mean in derry we pay 15 an hour
um you know they work for you know six
hours seven hours
they could go to court and even if they
win they could be out thousands of
dollars it there's no there's no reason
to participate
thank you thank you
does anybody have any questions for ms
gilford representative prudhomme o'brien
good morning thank you so much for
coming here and talking to us about your
experiences and for your service to our
community thank you
i'm
i'm wondering would you
uh
favor this bill if it only
included people that were elected
and
a little bit further than that is what
about people that have been trained what
if it was people that were elected and
people who had gone through training
um again
i i have issues with anyone who's not
elected
being subject to this
um because i think you know you know
when you put your name on the ballot
you're putting yourself out there
you're you're holding yourself up to a
higher standard
i think when people are trained and they
do something wrong
we had an incident in derry in 2020
where a
poll worker was um
basically electioneering it was caught
on video
um
and
uh that video was sent to the secretary
of state's office in the attorney
general's office
and that was prior to
my becoming town moderator
and
the
the attorney general's office took it
from there and i know at the end they
chose not to prosecute
that poll worker did reach out to me
when i got elected and said they'd be
willing to work and i was not interested
in hiring them
thank you further questions
representative teresa
thank you madam jim thank you man for
taking my question
so whether
a poll worker is elected or a volunteer
or not
um
if they commit a wrongful action in
regard to voting
uh procedures
should they not be held to the same
standard
see it's my job to know every rsa in and
out
you know someone who is hired and
trained
to do a particular job
even
you know even if they are an assistant
moderator they
they don't know all the little ins and
outs
and an innocent mistake could be made
but as a as the overarching moderator
it's my job to have my eyes everywhere
and watch that and correct anything that
may happen
thank you um
right i understand that but some of the
um
the actions we heard uh referenced
from the last witness um were things
whether you know the rsas or not seem to
be common sense shouldn't have happened
so um
do you think that um
in a case where it's a again a knowing
situation there should be some way to to
solve that
so it doesn't happen again well you know
we've had multiple polling places in the
past in derry if if there was a need to
transfer ballots between one polling
place and the other
you know there's a procedure there for
the town clerk and another election
official to do that
it wouldn't just be
i i mean
i don't even use the term pull warden it
wouldn't just be someone going over and
doing that like you have you do have to
follow the rules
and um
you know nobody would just send somebody
to go do that like it just makes no
sense
thank you further questions
i'm not seeing any thank you for coming
this morning thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill
is natch
grays welcome to the election law
committee match is from
the new hampshire municipal association
and i hope i pronounced your name right
thank you madam chair uh it's nature
gray's niche like nature okay great
thank you a bit unusual um
so i'm from nhma
we do object to this bill uh one of the
things we'd like to point out is there's
already a mechanism to remove
any town official who doesn't perform
their duties
that's because town officials must take
the oath of office
pursuant to uh rsa 42 colon one and that
oath of office is the oath of office in
the constitution part two article 84
which states the official
will faithfully and impartially
discharge and perform all duties and
comment on them
and if they don't they are subject to
removal
so there's no need to
add additional people who can come in
here and remove any town official
because that already exists
i guess there are a couple other items
that came up during the discussion uh
today that i'd like to address
um
the first is that uh
this bill doesn't have any
sort of penalty for a vexatious or
frivolous lawsuit so
if i don't like the result that comes
out of my polling place
or well as written it doesn't specify
polling place but i assume an amendment
would do that i could just go file suit
and allege that something has occurred
it there's no penalty for me doing that
at some point it could get thrown out
but it's going to cost
both the in potentially the individual
town official and almost certainly the
town
money to
fight that even if it's just to the
point of
a dismissal um to the point of you know
the court looking at it
seeing what the filings are and saying
well there's no allegation here there's
no penalty for me doing that i could
just go and do that because i don't like
the result
um and i could just allege that the
moderator or the clerk or whoever didn't
do their job
so that's a that's a big problem
that we foresee because of course
you could politicize this and that could
be a result that occurs
um
the other thing that i wanted to uh
point out is that
under the statute being modified rsa uh
666 colon 3
the first
provision is actually a a misdemeanor
and that's where the the intent is
any public officer whose duty relates to
elections
she'll knowingly fail to perform the
duty
is guilty of a misdemeanor and the
second section which is the new section
being added in
doesn't have a criminal penalty um and
presumably it wouldn't because any
registered voter can file the suit and
there's actually no
intent there it's just
any registered voter can bring the suit
against any of these election officials
for failure to perform their election
duties so there's no
willfulness there's no knowingly there's
no negligently there's nothing it's just
hey that i think this person failed to
perform their duties i'm suing
um so those are really the points i want
to make i'm happy to take questions
questions
representative terozian
thank you madam chair thank you uh for
taking the question
looking at part one in here maybe i'm
missing something you said it says any
public officer upon
uh duty relating to elections is imposed
who shall knowingly fail to perform such
duty or who shall knowingly perform in
such a way and so forth so the word
knowingly is in there i thought i heard
you say
just for clarification um i'll deal with
this
one
refers to a misdemeanor in the last line
which means it's a criminal action those
are not brought by individuals those are
brought they can be brought by
individuals but they are more commonly
brought by the state
two has to do with the actual individual
bringing suit
and
his position is is that the
act
intent or
qualification of knowingly does not
transfer to the second paragraph
thank you for the clarification okay
when i think i can do so ably i like to
take witnesses off the hot seat
thank you
any further questions for the witness
representative growing
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
so we we heard
of
infractions of
of elections election rules
and
the
you know it was acknowledged that those
are not common
correct but
if even if they're uncommon or even if
they go beyond uncommon to rare
it can change the outcome of elections
so
do you have
uh a recommendation as to how to deal
with these
issues in a timely way
without
this
process well based on what the sponsor
said and i'm not an elected official so
i i don't have this uh personal
knowledge but based on what the sponsor
said
it sounds like the secretary of state's
office may not have enough staff on
election day in order to address
concerns coming to them
um if that's the case
it certainly seems appropriate that the
secretary of state's office as the
overseer of the state's elections would
be the one to
deal with problems
um and they might need more staffing but
that's not something i would argue for
as an hma but certainly that seems to be
the linchpin here is if people are
making complaints and they're not
getting responses
um that perhaps it's the case that uh
we need more people so that they can
respond
further questions for the witness
seeing none thank you very much for
coming that is the last speaker i have
for 1567
in regards to this bill there was a
remote
testimony to the extent of opposing or
supporting the bill
uh 13 individuals registered as
supporting the bill 86 registered as
opposing the bill and representative
teroshian
and
three persons
two persons have signed up one in favor
one against
okay i'm closing the public hearing on
1567.
next we will move on to our second
hearing of the day which is hb 1485.
this is relative to direct recall
elections
on and i'm going to look to the last man
standing as to sponsors in this
committee that is here today to
introduce the bill
uh representative barry
representative sweeney again uh better
looking and smarter get that joke out of
the way
um
this is uh representative sweeney is the
prime sponsor on this bill i am a
co-sponsor on it um it is a bill um
do dealing with recall elections for
municipal offices with terms of three
years i believe they're going to look at
expanding that to three years or more
the purpose of the the overarching idea
is
in new hampshire we turn over virtually
or i shouldn't say virtually but the
overwhelming vast majority of offices
every two years
including being one of two states that
does it for governor
in our opinion meeting the other
sponsors that gives voters a good opport
a good bite at the apple every time they
elect somebody that maybe doesn't serve
their best interests um and everyone in
this room is a part of that and some of
us have been on both sides of that will
so
what i what we did try to do when
crafting it was set the bar high enough
to where the recall wouldn't be
frivolous
but it would be attainable so the way it
would work is there would be a petition
just very similar to a warrant article
except you would need 10
of the total registered voters in the
last general election
in the
um jurisdiction to sign the
the petition um at that point the
petition would go to the town clerk's
office where it could be certified if
the town clerk's office refuses to
certify it for
whatever reason we do offer redress
through the court system an expedited
redress
obviously there's some conflict of
interest if you're the town clerk and
you are
judging the petitions on your recall
whether or not they're legitimate or not
so we had to provide an escape valve
there
um
the
there can be a recall election i believe
representative sweeney is going to
address uh he's gonna address my
concerns with that which is i want that
recall election on an already occurring
election i know it's currently not
written like that
the election to replace
the uh if if the recall election takes
place there's another bar that has to be
hit
so it has to have it has to have an
election with at least 20 registered
voter turnout so that way 10 people
can't show up and punt somebody out of
office um and obviously there has to be
a majority of those voting
um
the election to um
the the election to replace someone um
if there is one we'll be at the next
regularly called election we don't want
to be shoving a bunch of elections down
on town clerks
um there is a provision in here
to this is something that i caught
so i
did see this representative sweeney and
i fixed it for you
i fixed what i referred to as the escape
hatch which is somebody's about to be
recalled
they resign real fast and then many of
these
many of these offices are when there's a
vacancy they are filled by an existing
board so there was an escape patch where
you could resign
the board could reappoint you and your
recall would be basically circumvented
so what this does do is it says if you
are subject to a recall and you resign
you may not be placed back in that
office but you may run for that office
again in the regular in the next regular
election for that office so it doesn't
preclude you from running in the future
but it does
it does um preclude you from using that
as an escape hatch
um and with that i will try to answer
these questions the best i can like i
said this was not um
i am a sponsor of this bill i am
supportive of the idea but i was not the
primary driver of it
questions representative tarosian thank
you madam chair thank you representative
perry for taking the question
i think i heard you say but i wasn't
sure that that you were going to correct
in other words this is for a three-year
term
so you're going to correct that so it
would include three three or more yes um
because there are terms in from this
pool office like i know in litchfield
the supervisor of the checklist serves a
six-year term um
so we will we will expand it out to
three-year terms
it's up to the committee if they want to
from the previous bill if they want to
bring it down to the two-year terms
but that's
our intention was the three-year terms
because we we do believe that
two-year cycles of cleaning out
politicians is gives the voters ample
opportunity to address
let's call it mistakes
um but three years and more you you know
if you elect somebody and they run on
campaign promise a and then they get in
and immediately stop do the opposite of
a you have to live under that for three
years
and we don't think that that's right
further questions representative growing
thank you representative barry for
taking my question and uh certainly not
from somebody that's uh smarter or
better looking
smarter maybe maybe older and wiser
um
but anyway uh
the
you you just mentioned three or more
years but the bill specifically says
three years is that something you plan
to imagine correct i was when i was
reading it this morning going oh my god
joe what'd you get me into i went oh he
missed that
um so yeah that has that's supposed to
be three or more i do know that for a
fact
thank you further questions for
representative barry
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you
i i know you may not be able to answer
this because you say you're not the
driver of this but the
better looking mr
sweeney is
was there any incident
that you can recall that was
the motivation for drafting this um so i
could speak personally to that um so as
you know i represent the town of
litchfield as well
and in litchfield we have it's it's very
standard right school where members
usually serve for three years um
we had a school board that signed that
released this document to parents at the
beginning of remote learning
it was a dei document
and in the dei document was a list of
links to things that my voters found
objectionable they did the classic pack
the school board
meeting there were things in that
document about defunding the police
and
the school board i went to that board
meeting i didn't take a massive position
on it i'm not a resident of the town you
know if i had children they wouldn't go
to that school system but i do represent
that town and what i told the school
board at the time was you guys they were
trying to shortchange the meeting they
were trying to limit public comment cut
it down to 10 minutes in total not 10
minutes per person 10 minutes in total
and i told them you guys need to listen
you need to basically take your lumps on
this one you messed up
and they
they were indignant
would be the best way to describe that
and i don't think that they were
malicious in this
and i said it at the time i didn't think
they were malicious i didn't think it
was intentional but they tried to cover
it up and shift blame
um all of them did and to have somebody
who was in my opinion um attempting to
cover things up they were holding
executive session meetings for things
that were not personnel matters
specifically about this issue so they
were trying to hide from the public
and that's not acceptable to me and it's
not acceptable to
the voters that i represent in
litchfield they have to wait for three
years while this person's persons while
they cycle out these persons or have the
opportunity to cycle out these persons
um so that was the impetus when they
propose it to me i said yeah we need to
be able to clean these out a little more
regularly
and once again i don't think it was
malicious with what they did the
document was appalling um but i i get
that when things are moving quick and
covet was crazy times but it's um you
know the cover-ups worse than the crime
so
further question representative
prudhomme o'brien
what is a dei document uh diversity
equity inclusion it was a document they
sponsored after george floyd like i said
there were things in the document that
weren't objectible but they provided a
list of links for parents
and the one that really got me going was
they had a link to a document that
supported defunding the police
as a political position
and once again i'm not trying to draw
condemnation on the document itself the
document they they admitted that the
document was inappropriate after it was
after we packed a school board meeting
but their behavior
leading up to it the executive session
that shouldn't have been an executive
session because as most of you were
involved in
some form of executive town government
you know that executive session is used
almost exclusively for personnel matters
school boards will use it for matters
pertaining to a particular student
but this was a matter of effectively
curriculum it was being distributed to
parents as a resource document it had no
business and executive session and they
they tried to cover it up and and and i
get it i wouldn't have wanted to be on
camera for that either if that's what i
was doing
but the reality is that's what they did
they got caught and they were pretty
unremorseful about it
further question representative kelly
thank you madam chairman
you talk about the school board
and they are three year terms
but they're not all at the same time
correct so there is a um
there is a provision in here i believe
at least i told joe it needed to be in
there
that basically limits when the
recall can happen
so it can't happen immediately after an
election or within a certain time period
beforehand if it's not in there it
should have been because i told him it
needed to be in there
um because basically when they when they
came to me with this idea i said you
know i like the idea but i don't want to
be abused um
so it should be in there if it's not but
if it's not it definitely i will i will
tell you i'll be putting it in there
because i do not want at the bottom of
page two at the bottom of page two and
that's what i thought
um
it should be it should be a certain time
limit in here
um
actually staying corrected page one page
one
oh here we go yep no application for
recall petition shall be filed during
the first 180 days or during the last
180 days of any official term so that
was a that was a provision that i
demanded that be in there because it's
it's ridiculous if somebody gets elected
and you don't like them and you
immediately file a recall petition on
them it's also ridiculous to hold a
recall petition for someone you're going
to be voting on within 180 days so
trying to find an actual balanced
approach to this because i don't want it
to
be abused or get off the rails
further question
actually i never got to my question
um sorry about that welcome to election
law
so uh
essentially because you have the 180
days before 180 days after
essentially
on a school board
you would only
you would not be able to
do a recall on the majority of the
school board correct maybe one depending
on the school board
maybe two
which
means that
even if you were successful in your
recall
you're still going to have them the same
majority
and i'm just wondering if
what you think about this
all of this stuff the expense to the
town
for a situation where it's not going to
change the outcome of what's going on in
the school board
so to that effect as i said in the
beginning
one of the things that all the
co-sponsors agree upon is that two years
is is a good amount of time
to change people out
and this operates within that window um
to answer your question about the i mean
i guess to your point is you're asking
about the burden on the town um
obviously we did try to pair up the
elections with the existing elections um
i've said before in this committee that
i don't want an election
just here and there because the wins
changed
which is why we put in these
pretty large bumpers if you will
to stop that from occurring but it is a
very you know it's a very valid point
that you make you know there will be an
election there will be a recall um there
will be a cost to that um but ultimately
you know that's um that's that is one of
the functions of government so i am
extremely judicious about when we create
new elections if you will um and i am
extremely judicious with the taxpayers
dollars i understand town resources
dollars are precious i understand they
come from property taxes
i am extremely sensitive to all those
issues
and like with all things in government
there is a balancing act
further questions from the committee
representative growing
thank you madam chair and uh
representative berry i just want
clarification based on the the last
discussion here that this recall
is
strictly individual it's not recalling a
board is that correct correct it
actually specifically says that in the
um language that a recall provision can
only be used for one
for one but the petition can only be
used for one individual i guess there
could be a situation where
people signed up for as many as they as
they could but once again the 180-day
provision
the length of the office of terms it's
it's it's an intentionally narrow scoped
um
legislation to put and it's not just
about school board members there's
selectmen in um zoning boards and all
sorts of things that can have two three
uh three four-year terms um
and it just you know i think part of it
is is if you're in a like i said the the
town of litchfield posted there hey this
is what's going to be on the municipal
ballot in march uh they actually did
yesterday
and the supervisor checklist is going to
run for a six year term um and if you're
sitting there for six you know you get
in there and you're in year and year one
and you're like well you know i can i
can do or not do this job well and i'll
have four years to correct it um well
maybe not um so the idea is we know we
should always be accountable to the
voters
we should always be attuned to them some
of us are better at it than others some
of us think we're better at it than we
are
but
i think
with the new hampshire system of
government 400 state representatives
cycling every two years the government
cycles every two years our our citizen
legislator
is designed to be accountable to the
voters at all times and by having these
these um positions that are longer than
two years we kind of they kind of get
removed from that accountability
people's memories are are short uh and
there's some good things and there's bad
things obviously the united states
senate six year term for a reason
they're supposed to be the the gentle
person's body and and we're supposed to
work together um you know there's good
and bad things about not being able to
change people out but um it is my
opinion and the way new hampshire system
of government is set up is you get a
bite at that apple pretty often unless
you have a three four five six year term
and then you don't further questions
representative lane
thank you madam chair um thank you
representative
i guess
a three year term you have a 180 day
window 180 day window so it basically
leaves you with a two-year term right
um well to do the conductive recall no
it's not two years it's because it's
it's before or after but
it's designed for people who for the
three year term specifically it's
designed for people who get in office
and immediately
cease to perform or perform counter to
what they promised um for those remember
it's it's three there are longer terms
in three years right but to your point
yes you're making the point that's a
very narrow window i assume
right now
and we're talk anyway i just
i'm
just
that's real that's all i'm done
thank you yeah it's a very valid point
it's it's it's i'm not gonna refute that
point it's it's the the
the reason this thing is is so scoped is
bluntly because of me because i said if
you're gonna get me on board with this
you need to
you need to put some big guard rails on
this because it um
this gets abused in other states and i i
don't like that bluntly um that you have
to have if there's stability of
government issues underlying that if
you're just constantly making runs at it
um but i i think when you have those
once again when you have those long
terms and they're out of reach and
there's no recourse um that's a problem
but i want to put it you know within
reach but not you know oh it's tuesday
i'm going to wake up and i'm going to
recall my school remember
further questions representative
prudhomme o'brien
so
earlier you this is a follow-up to what
you said about the board in litchfield
and that they
experienced some disappointed parents
and then they went and talked about the
situation they weren't you thought they
weren't um responsive you said they went
into executive session did you mean
non-public session correct i'm sorry
non-public section that's what i feel
yes i'm sorry non-public section yes
they went at
section i apologize yes they were that's
what that's exactly what i meant
i'm in legislative mode what can i say
further questions
i
representative barry that i have a
question in regards to clarification
um if you look at line 10 page one
it it refers to
and also five and six a local elected
official
so
is the intent that this would not be
a
senator
to the u.s senate owned yes no it is not
a congressional official to the u.s
congress correct so it is only um yes
that is a hundred percent the attempt it
is only for um local elected officials
it is not for congress is not for every
two years but it would not be for you a
senate president i guess if you wanted
to
can't do that um recall that that'd be
an interesting concept we're going to
recall our electors
that'd be a fun little exercise where's
your head when you need him um
all right so in follow-up to that
it is
you were trying to put guardrails on
this for
essentially local officials that would
appear on a ballot
generally speaking not in september or
november usually those are
municipal run elections that occur
anywhere between march and i think june
is the last date you can have
all right so
my question is why were the was the
signature
requirement
based
on
registration at the time of the general
election is that a is that a function of
checklist maintenance or or if we're
talking about local elections yeah um
that's a function of me demanding a high
bar to execute it um because
i understand what this i understand the
ramifications of of this concept um and
i i was trying to make it as palatable
as possible
while still achieving the underlying
goal
and i understand that then no matter
what we do there will be members who
don't support this
but i did make a good faith effort on my
end in talking with joe like you need to
do x y and z um because otherwise it's
just going to get wrapped up as a
partisan bill and and getting to put in
that bin it wasn't my intention to do
that
thank you other
questions i'm not seeing any thank you
very much for
introducing this bill also signed up to
speak on 1485 is nate grays
thank you madam chair nate graves for
the new hampshire municipal association
again um i should have mentioned in my
prior testimony and i will now can you
get a little closer to the mic i
actually texted to make sure that you
could be heard and sure
um i do have written testimony which was
submitted online so hopefully you've had
the opportunity to review that
um
i i guess
preliminarily my
question
would be
if the intent of the sponsors is that
they like new hampshire's traditional
election cycle of a two-year cycle
why wouldn't we just adjust everyone's
terms to be two years rather than have a
recall
i don't have an answer to that but that
i was just throwing that out there
and i'm pointing that out because the
bill is is somewhat arbitrary
as uh i'm sure many of you know
there are local options for how long
local officials serve terms so for
example
clerks and treasurers
typically serve a term of one year
unless the town has opted for a
three-year term
similarly
a highway agent who is elected either
serves one two or three years so
at the local level you you end up making
that decision about what's appropriate
for your town for at least some
positions
uh and
depending on what decision you make if
this bill were to go into effect that
person may or may not be subject to a
recall
which seems somewhat arbitrary
additionally
we are
concerned that
there really isn't
anything that ties the
officials performance
of their duties to the recall um so
while they while an allegation does have
to be made about
um
or a statement made about the recall
it really doesn't necessarily tie to
what their action is so
you know it could be the case that
someone does
spend that first 180 days to gather
signatures and then on day 181 file it
uh against the
official and it could be the loser in
the in the election um so we're
concerned certainly about the
possibility of abuse here
um
and that's really
the the major the major point um besides
that
we're also concerned about holding these
special elections certainly if it is
something that
ends up uh being abused i'm not saying
that's the case but if it is something
that ends up being abused
and you end up having to have special
elections
you know those those elections are going
to cost money you're going to have to
find volunteers to perform the elections
you're going to have to you know call
out the moderator and everyone else
and the cost of that range ranges um so
small towns typically cost a couple
hundred dollars to run an election
um but a larger one is going to be about
ten thousand or more
and so that can add up pretty quickly uh
and municipalities are may have to start
budgeting for
you know some
some routine amount of money to to hold
these extra elections as they may be
thank you thank you
any questions
i'm seeing none thank you for coming
thank you
that is the the last pink card that i
have on hbo b1485
we did have remote testimony
registration
in connection with that 11 people signed
up supporting it and there were 38
opposed to it
thank you
representative terozian has provided me
with the sign up sheet and there were
two persons in attendance today at lob
who signed up
with a position on 1485 one in favor and
one opposed
i'm going to close the hearing on 1485
our next hearing is scheduled for 11
o'clock and we will reconvene then thank
you
oh it's that
let's just see if it oh yeah it is
actually okay
all right good aft good morning still
everyone um this is the new hampshire
house election law committee we are back
in schedule
for our public hearings at 11
a.m we have scheduled hb
1470 requiring that all ballot counting
devices show the number of overvotes for
each race on the ballot and with us here
to introduce the bill to committee it's
representative mike moff at the
welcome
thank you madam chair
happy to be here again i was with you
folks last week i brought
my my name plate because i'm bouncing
around between three different
committees and i'm going to egress as
soon as i offer these remarks but i will
be followed by
uh at least one or two people who have
some very good knowledge of
of this issue for the record again my
name is uh representative mike moffitt
representing canterbury and loudoun it's
merrimack district nine
so this measure is very simple short and
sweet
uh and it's simply amends rsa 659 colon
73 section 4 by inserting subparagraph j
as follows and that so that would be
sub paragraph k
and it simply says for each election
contest or ballot question the number of
machine counted overvotes
uh and i have i did send or try to send
the entire committee electronically this
testimony uh
late last night so it you should have
that
so a cup some quick bullets uh this bill
is intended to provide the number of
machine counted over votes over votes
for each race on the ballot where an
electronic ballot counting device is in
use
currently only a total number of
overvotes for each machine is available
to my understanding
so the only way to see which race or
races head over votes is with recounts
or a special audit
by hand
so this allows every candidate to see
how many machine counted overvotes
occurred in their race
and this can be very helpful in deciding
whether or not to file a recount and if
we don't need a recount then that saves
as you know a whole lot of time and
energy in expense
in derry
in november 2020 they reported over 500
overvotes on the machine that was used
exclusively for absentee ballots which
was
became a concern
and there's no way to know which race or
races had over 500 votes that were lost
in that particular machine
and and again back to to windom again
the audit there showed that folded
ballots are a problem and that's the
measure that i introduced to this
committee last week
regarding folded ballots
in this case attributed to ballots not
being folded the right way
so this bill if it had been in effect
earlier would have shown the miscount in
windham
was mostly for the representative race
it would have saved
needing to
to count all the other races
this bill would not apply to hand count
towns nor would it apply to hand-counted
ballots in machine count
uh towns and cities and
in
voting areas
so
this bill is important if we continue to
use ballot counting machines i know
there's a measuring to do away with them
and that's something this committee will
deal with but especially if we continue
to put folded ballots into these
machines this bill becomes even more
important
and
i'll try to take one question if while
i'm here if there is one
there any questions for representative
moffett who clearly has had enough of
the election law committee this morning
all right representative again
yeah
go ahead
thank you thank you madam chairman uh
representative uh muffet thanks for
being here
could you explain to me what an overvote
is
sure uh
when the ballots are counted uh
oftentimes there are
you have a certain number of uh
registered voters and
overvotes
are
particularly with machine basically it's
a function of machines the
number of votes don't line up uh
you know they're not in sync with the
number of voters
and
that could
there'll be someone following me i know
uh alvin c who's here a lot uh had
worked with me in the languages he can
speak to that as well
uh with regard to
exactly what the overvote issue
involves and how it's constituted or
defined
not the best answer but there's other
folks coming
and i thank you so much for your
flexibility actually right on time so
thank you for coming representative
thank you and i will step off
all right uh the only other pink card i
have for this is alvin c if alvin
is set to go welcome
thank you madam chairman members of
committee my name is alvin c i live in
loudoun i'm here
speaking for myself and no organization
and
let me start off with the overvote
is
say for governor it says vote for
no more than one
if you vote for two that's an overvote
for say a representative race where it
says vote for no more than four
if you vote for five that's an overvote
if you vote for three that's an
undervote
um
and so alvin just mr c just to continue
the description for people who are not
aware because i think generally
committee members are
what happens when there's an overvote in
a machine
in the machines
if it senses an overvote that you voted
for too many
it
just shows that it
records that as a zero for that office
so if it thinks you voted for five
which was more than the four you should
have voted for then none of those four
get a vote
if you undervote those
if you undervoted and only put in three
of the four names counted
um
in
when when ballots are hand counted
the effect of an overvote
is
is still the same
it negates that whole race
the reason being that the voters intent
cannot be determined
okay just i just want to make sure we
are all talking about the same thing as
we proceed thank you all right yeah and
in the case of of windham
there were uh the machine because the
ballots were
through the target ovals
that's where the machine
misinterpreted
some of those
as votes or
not votes
and
as far as the hand counted ballots
whether it's a hand count town or a
machine countdown the hand counted
ballots there
we're not worried about those because
those will have already had human eyes
looking at them trying to determine
voter intent
and
i'd like to suggest that this should
also apply to the
new ballot counting devices that the
town of milford recently received
permission to test this year
those machines will actually take a
digital image of the ballot
and then process the digital
result to find
where the votes were
and give a result but we need to find
any quirkiness in the new machines
before they get too far
in use
and also the effective date if this bill
passes it should be for this year's
state primary and general election
and i'm happy to answer any questions if
there are any
questions from committee members
representative hamlet
yeah thank you great madam chair and
thank you mr c for taking my question
i'm still confused can you pull the mic
a little closer i'm just being sort of
i'm worried about things can you hear me
now yeah no that's a little bit okay i'm
confused because
the accu-vote machines that we use in
portsmouth do count the overvotes
so what it what is the uh
what is it that i'm missing here in the
case of the uh way the accuvope machines
are currently programmed it gives you a
summary of of any overvotes on the
entire ballot
so you don't know whether it was for
state rep or for governor
or county commissioner
it just says at the top on the header
that there were so many people voted
there were so many
total overvotes counted but it doesn't
say which office
what this is doing
is to have the machines programmed
so that
for each office
it would
not only give you the
vote count for each of the candidates
plus
any write-ins
and number of blanks because some people
don't vote for all offices
but it also add in there the number of
overvotes that the machine counted in
that particular race
so it'll tell you if there's an
overvotes for
president or governor or state rep
or county commissioner
and you can use that information if if
you lose a race by say 50 votes and you
see there their 75
overvotes recorded it'd be worth your
while to ask for a recount
follow-up yeah follow-up um
so but i thought that they do list the
overvotes for each
for each race so you mean they
you should list the overvotes for each
candidate
yes well for each race for governor
it would say how many overvotes there
right if you've got two candidates for
governor it doesn't say how many
overvotes for sununu and how many
overvotes for
uh pelties
okay so you mean for each candidate
well as opposed to each race
no it would be each race for each race
because you can't
just if the with the committees indus
let's say it's a governor's race sununu
and feltus yes somebody fills out both
ovals yes it will have a total for
sununu a total for feltus those would be
the ballots with one clear bullet
filled in once
and then it will say
blanks
yes and it will have a number so it
can't it can't do it by candidate it has
to do it by race
because that's the tally is by race not
by individual
okay i thought we'd do it by race
already but maybe um
no i think
the testimony is we do not do it by race
it's a it's a total at the top of the
tape for the machine that's correct
right and also this should include any
ballot questions should there be any
okay thank you very much
further questions representative
terozian
thank you madam chair thank you mr c for
taking the question so the older
machines that are in use the active vote
and some of the others
um
are they
set up can they be programmed to do that
to give the breakdown for each race
uh yes the um in the
fiscal report
on this bill
the second paragraph the secretary of
state's office indicated that
the machines are capable of this
it's just that the
state for whatever reason had chosen not
to implement that
most other states do
report this
further questions from committee
representative
it was
okay
representative hamer
yeah i have a copy of um the tape
from our last election in manchester
ward 10.
um blanks is the first
item
in that
the ward 10 school committee which my
husband was
the winner
blanks was 151
my husband
752 and then the other candidate was
662.
write-ins two
so isn't that
the blanks for that
office
right so the blanks as my understanding
includes people who didn't vote right
because you have a right to not vote and
the overvotes the it so the blanks is
the equivalent
and the secretary of state's here i'm
sort of looking over here is the blanks
is essentially the number of ballots for
which there was no
vote recorded
either because the voter did not fill it
out at all
or it was filled out in a manner that
the machine determined there were too
many choices made
and right now the way the tape is
presented you can't tell the difference
between
where the voter intentionally did not
fill in a circle or did it incorrectly
am i getting that right
perfect okay the machine doesn't have
the ability to determine voter intent
right thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none
thank you for your testimony
also signed up to speak on 1470 is ken
eyring
good morning good morning
i don't have too much to add i agree
with everything that was said
uh for me this is an election integrity
issue and
after the november third election
as i mentioned yesterday a lot of people
on both sides of the fence this is
really nonpartisan
i've expressed concerns and wanting to
make sure that we tighten up our
elections so that
voters will have confidence in them
i live in wyndham so i'm very familiar
with what took place
there regarding the elections and the
enormous amount of overvotes on one of
our machines
and those overvotes were
were caused by
you know ballot folds being in the wrong
place
now this bill
won't address
the issue of
making sure that those particular
malfunctions in the machine
will correct the results of a particular
election because the paper tapes are
printed at the end of the day
but what it does do is it makes it very
clear
some more details as to why the
overvotes occurred and where they
occurred so it allows
election officials in each town if there
are an exorbitant amount of overvotes
to troubleshoot and see where the issues
are
and in windham we had one machine
that had
an enormous amount of overvotes 292. so
for 292 people
who went in and voted assuming that all
of those were machine malfunctions
and i would have to i would bet that a
vast majority of them were
that it would have been very very
helpful to know
at the point at the end of the day that
all of those overvotes or a vast
majority of them were related to the
state rep race
and when you go and you look at
secretary
of state bill gardner at the time and
scanlan who was here they ran the
recount and i was there
and
their results which and they handled
that very very well their results showed
that there was approximately 300 votes
for every republican candidate plus or
minus three votes that were not awarded
to the republican candidates
on election day by the machines
and then the leading democrat
uh candidate was awarded an extra 99
votes on election day so there was a
swing
of from a a losing margin of 24 votes on
election day to 420 votes
after the recount
and like i said this is not just a
this is not a partisan issue because if
you go to a town like
um like sandown
uh
it appears that the same type of issue
happened there
and so we have to but
in favor of the republicans because
as i'm sure you know
the ballots are set up with three
columns
and the party in each column
it's a third a third a third and they
shift every year
and um
and according to the
audit that took place on the window
machines trying to figure out what was
wrong with the problem
uh they
they discovered that
the particular machine that had this
issue
it was it had more of a susceptibility
to have the issue in the center column
and so um
you know
to
wrap this up i just believe it would be
very very helpful for it's a tool
essentially for our moderators
that they can then after the fact go
and have somebody look at this and they
can actually uh
you know determine whether or not
there's there's issues and as um
as mr c pointed out it also would make
it a tool for the candidates because in
the case of uh
of wyndham where there was an enormous
amount of overvotes if if you're all
running for election
whether you want you know if you lose by
a certain number and the overvotes are
some magnitude greater than that you
know that there's a potential for the
machines to have failed and it's only
right for you to then go
and ask for a recount to make sure that
they were that the votes were counted
properly by the machines so thank you
very much for your time i appreciate
everything that you do for our state any
questions from committee members
i'm seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
chao kelly
morning good morning chairman griffin
thank you for giving me the time to
speak about this one
prior to
november 6 i mean november 3rd election
i have no clue what an overvote means
and i attended
that 15 days of the um
forensic audit of windham i've learned a
lot
along the way
and i saw many familiar faces here that
circled that place too because
i did not know that the machine can take
your ballot but it doesn't count
and with the amount of like 300 per
candidate
in windham
without a hand recount you wouldn't know
what happened
and the person who requested that
recalls is a democrat even though the
republican won there so
um
these machines have problem and i
testified last week that
i would prefer to get rid of all of the
voting machine because
if people have the result less than a
certain margin they wouldn't do the
recount
you wouldn't imagine that it would be
like 300
without that sp
whatever the bills
to have that recount so
preferably we get rid of all the machine
if it has to be still there
then please sort it out so that
we know which machine because i've
circled a lot of elections after that
and a certain machine place a certain
place in the election that is meant just
to feed
absentee ballots and the ballers and
from what i hear which i cannot verify
there's a lot of funny businesses going
on
and in election integrity that is why
i've been camping here for the last few
days and last week because i lost faith
in our election process and i don't
believe that my vote matters anymore
so that's why we need to take this small
step to allow the people in that process
at that time to check and at the end of
the resolve the election
the public
and the candidate
had the tool to determine and somehow in
the future if the candidate choose not
to have the recount the public
who support those candidates should have
the ability to do so because right after
the election of november i asked many
people to do recall and they say no no
we don't want to do that because we have
to rerun
why
the result is not right doesn't matter
how many times you run it's not going to
be right if there's something wrong in
there that we don't fix which we did not
check we could not check it
so the public should have the ability to
inspect it because the candidate afraid
of their reputation and their stigma or
whatever that going on with it so they
won't risk that but we the people lost
that vote
and that's faith so we need to be able
to inspect to make sure that it's
accurate
so i ask you to please support this bill
so that you know we can slowly
restore the faith of the voters
and to keep us fit with the first in the
nation status
thank you
thank you for your testimony is there
are there any questions from committee
members
i'm seeing none thank you for testimony
thank you
that was the last speaker i had signed
up on hb 1470 there were persons who
signed up remotely in position on 1470.
i have 16
a list of 16 individuals who signed up
in support two opposed and one neutral
thank you representative tarosian
and there was
also
someone signed up to speak in favor of
it
excuse me signed up on the blue sheet in
favor who also spoke
so with that i'm going to close close
the hearing on 1470.
um
oh i'm sorry yeah
thank you madam chair
i was just wondering if i could get one
quick question answered by the secretary
of state
sure
so um i haven't quite closed the hearing
um
how's that
ignore what i just said i can say
whatever time i want in this room and i
can reopen something that might have
just for a nanosecond been closed
um
if the sec if the secretary of state or
another member of the office wants to um
come up to why don't you tell us what
the question is and then they can decide
who should come up to him
the question is uh one of the things
that was said
uh in the testimony was that
this is just a programming issue
for existing
uh machines
is that correct or do we need to
change our machines
that was if you were just watching that
was what you would refer to as passing
the buck i think down there between
those three individuals
um
so let's see i just gave it a little
more time for the short straw to come
forward all right
yeah good morning madam chair and
honorable committee members uh as far as
your
question representative i know within
the fiscal note that state that the airs
we would have to definitely verify with
lhs that it can definitely be turned on
for each machine um even as a clerk i
don't remember whether or not it was
able to be turned on to the machine so
this question that i definitely would
want to pose to our vendor
so do you think you could pose that
question to the vendor so we have an
answer
okay yes and we'll get back to the
committee
you're very welcome thank you
anything else on 1470
thank you and i apologize for closing
that a little too early
the next bill that we have scheduled
here in committee
is
1457 relative to the chain of custody
of ballot boxes after
election is there anybody here for 1457
um
here comes the prime sponsor okay great
if
right on time
pink card and you're on
target you can pass it in afterwards why
don't you have a seat because i know
you've got other stuff going on too so
welcome to the election law committee
this is 1457 relative to the chain of
custody of ballot boxes after an
election
and with us to introduce the bill as the
prime sponsor of the bill welcome
thank you madam chair the members of the
committee i am michael yukovovich
from hooksett representing merrimack 24
and i'm presenting the bill about the
chain of custody of the ballots
and the boxes
um so
this yeah this must be very fun
committee
i couldn't exit into the hall the other
day
from my committee
and but i'm here i'm not here to talk
about fraud or fake or any elections
anything like that i'm here to talk
about transparency accountability and
reproducibility
this is what happens after the election
the
voters ballots get stored in boxes the
boxes get stored in towns they use
there's no uniformity every town does
their own thing they may be stored they
may not be stored somebody may be
singing on them
who knows what
so um
there's
there's a bunch of bills coming forward
probably that deal with audits and um
recounts for the ballot so i believe
it's in our best interest to keep those
ballots and boxes secure after the
election so we can look at them we can
reproduce the results
so my bill calls for the storage of
these boxes for the boxes to be
safely moved to
probably concord to a secure location so
they can be kept there after the
election
um
this way we can provide the utmost care
for the boxes we can satisfy the voters
that everything possible is being done
to the
ballots
as submitted
in in a couple of elections in this
recent cycle bedford is a prime example
where uh ballots were discovered after
the election months after the election
the public only learned about such
instances a year down the road this is
really
irresponsible my bill would prevent that
um
this is yeah that's that's about all i
have um the only change or the only
concern that i have in the bill is that
it
in the fiscal note they say that the
boxes will be stored
in perpetuity
permanently and that's not something i
desired but
so i am for
storing of boxes for
up to two years
i think the way it's done today
so that they don't need to be stored
permanently that obviously will
require unlimited space
thank you thank you so it wasn't your
intent to change the storage requirement
the time period no no it was not
all right
questions from committee members
i'm not seeing any so thank you very
much for coming and introducing the bill
thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
ken eyring
hi thank you again for the chance to
speak on this
um
when i first read this bill
a few months ago or whenever yeah a few
months ago
i was i was up in the air because i'm a
true believer in local control
and i think that having our ballots
in multiple places you know under
different people i think that helps
normally with election integrity
but after the report from the ag's
office and the secretary of state's
office that was
sent out the letter that was sent to
local election officials in windham
regarding their handling of the november
3rd 2020 election
it's an 11-page report
it
identifies
multiple violations of law multiple
violations of the
procedures for handling the ballots
and running the election and it's very
disturbing
and i think that in light of that of
my opinion has shifted towards it it
might be better
to have
our ballots
overseen by the secretary of state's
office
because it allows it would allow them to
see some of these issues
firsthand for instance
and i'm going off the top of my head so
if you read the report or if you read
the report
and i get some of these things wrong
it's just the intent that i'm trying to
infer
but i think there were half a dozen
boxes that weren't even sealed properly
there were others that didn't have
the um
the security tape on them there were
others that didn't have signatures on
the security tape i mean these are
these are severe in my opinion
violations of the law because you want
to ensure that when the ballots go into
the boxes and then they're sealed
that they're sealed and
with tamper-proof tape so that you can
you can have some kind of confidence
that they're being stored and handled
properly
and you know i don't mean to be critical
of of anybody in particular i'm deciding
what was written in their report
and there are issues there so
in the sense of if you trans if you have
the each town transfer those boxes up to
the secretary of state's office and any
and there are any irregularities with
the handling of the ballots and the
boxes the secretary of state's office
would be immediately aware of that
and they could notify the town and they
could provide proper training to make
sure that in the future
those ballots were handled properly the
boxes were sealed properly with all the
you know um
um
tamper proof tape and and all the
signatures and and whatnot so that's all
i had to offer you know thank you again
for your time
questions from committee members
i uh
mr eyring i actually have a couple since
you volunteered that you're from wyndham
and you're aware of the 11-page letter
um
one of the things in windham that was
found is that the boxes that were
provided by the secretary of state's
office to to
package store the ballots in after
they were used were not used and the
wyndham officials swore that those boxes
were not delivered until after the
election and in fact the letter
discloses that there's a receipt that
they were delivered days before the
election
would your bill correct that kind of
conduct well you know
it's not your bill it would this bill
correct that kind of conduct well it
would make
the state officials aware
immediately
that the boxes were not used
okay clearly they were delivered on time
because they have receipts
so you know whatever happened in wyndham
whatever the reasons are they didn't use
it i can't speak on that but that's one
of the uh violations you know our law
says you have to you know our town
officials election officials have to use
the boxes that are provided by the
secretary of state and they weren't so
in addition to the other issues i
brought up they didn't use the proper
boxes as well and then the secretary of
state's office could address that type
of issue immediately
and make sure in the future
that they are used because there's
reasons for all of these laws they add
to the integrity of our elections and
the storage of the ballots so that you
would have the state same response in
regards to the failure to seal the boxes
properly and the failure to sign the
seal on the boxes properly yeah
absolutely and for me that's really
disturbing i'm really disturbing you
know there's absolutely no no reason why
our ballots
once they're put into permanent storage
which is on election night
and opened only currently only in the
event of
a recount they should be
stored as defined by law and that was
not followed so
um in in essence i look at this as a
tool for for ensuring
that our ballots are stored properly and
that they're they're given the type of
due diligence
according to the law
and it puts the secretary of state's
people
in a position where they can help i'm
not looking to penalize anybody or to
say that you know people should be
removed from their positions i'm why not
i guess i have to ask well if the state
incurred thousands and thousands of
dollars in costs for an audit that
appears to have been caused by people
not doing their job i'm glad you said
that in the case of windham i have a
different opinion
but for this bill
i'm not looking there i'm not trying to
suggest that the secretary of state's
office should be there with an iron fist
and come down on all the towns
because there's going to be you know
human error people have you know they
don't they make mistakes we all make
mistakes
it's a tool to to help ensure that our
ballots are going to be properly managed
and i think that this is a good idea and
i didn't feel strongly about that until
i saw that report and if you haven't
read the report
i strongly suggest that you take time to
read it it's 11 pages but it's it's a
pretty quick read
committee members have a copy of it
thank you any further questions for mr
eyring and thank you all for indulging
the chair representative prudhomme
o'brien thank you
uh i know that you've been very active
in that situation in windham
is
this is a yeah my question is
do you think that there's awareness in
your community that there is an upcoming
election i mean
i don't live in windham so i'm i'm
uh i'm assuming there is because there
isn't and derry is there an upcoming
election for
clerk and and moderator and is there a
lack of awareness in your community that
other people can
run for those positions and
what's happening well i don't know who's
going to run
i believe one of our moderator positions
is open
and
i don't believe currently that a lot of
people in windham are aware of the
issues but i intend to you know do my
best to make sure that people are aware
by just putting out the facts and
letting people come to their own
conclusions but as
chairwoman griffin pointed out it was an
enormous
endeavor
to go through uh the
what we went through trying to figure
out what happened
uh you know with
with the election results from 11 3 and
then all of the subsequent
irregularities
and and there's it's not just that there
are other issues regarding with how the
elections are run but that's not germane
to this bill so i won't bring them up
thank you further questions from
committee members
seeing none thank you mr thank you very
much
also signed up to speak on this bill is
christina gilford
welcome back thank you
thank you committee um christina gilford
derry town and school moderator i
actually wasn't going to speak on this
bill but the more i look at it the more
i have an issue here
and it's probably a very easy issue to
correct
um there is something here in this bill
that when a
um
absentee ballot comes in late
that the clerk should just destroy it
they enter in an election net and they
destroy it
and i do not think that anything of this
nature should be destroyed i mean we're
talking about election integrity here
that's what everybody wants
um i think that either the town clerk
should retain them
for whatever the holding period is
or
um something should be worked out but
just to
have the say so of the town clerk yep it
came in late rip up an envelope i mean
somebody still voted even if it came in
late and it didn't get counted this
should it should still be held with
everything else
i i don't like just destroying him and
throwing them in the trash it just seems
wrong
thank you
questions for members of the committee
representative pimentel
thank you madam chairman i
i'm just curious
as far as
what this would do if there were
a local recount
if you're shipping your ballots all the
way
to the
secretary of state's office
well
at this point in time we don't send any
ballots for local elections to the
secretary of state's office
um
if it all they all go to concord then i
guess the secretary of state's office
would have to handle any local recounts
they would have the ballots
thank you
thank you but i think this bill is just
for state and general elections but i
might have missed that
further questions representative barry
just more of a clarifying i think it's
uh
the line two of the bill in any state
election i guess
in any state election
so i believe this only deals with state
elections i can't speak for this for the
sponsors but
well i
i think somebody from the secretary of
state's office is going to testify and
i'd like clarification of that because
that first paragraph of the bill deals
with absentee votes so the actual
transport i want to make sure we need
clarification on what that applies to
also signed up to speak on this bill is
chow kelly
thank you madam chair
um
yeah i am
i saw this is a big problem
at the um
windham audit
is because the first day
all those boxes that got in there
one of the observer
linda brown
from i think
sandow
she was checking and trying to take
picture of all these blocks to compare
to the list the change of custody list
and there's one box that has the same
number with another box
and she has been trying
to ask all these officials the three
auditors there
for that whole time and i have video
eyewitnesses because like i said i was
there every day for 15 days
from open to close
she'd been trying to get them to clarify
that and they couldn't they wouldn't
they keep avoiding her
so on the last day
she stopped
secretary of state garnier
and talked to him and asked him to help
her identify that box she had pictures
she printed out in color at the whole
video of that i posted on youtube people
watching it and let me tell you what the
face in the elections like just go
sinking down
and he promised to try to get it back to
her but there's nothing back okay so
it's a big problem with the change of
custody
because if you have let's say 20 boxes
in
all the supplies and other ballasts and
now you have a box that has the same
number with the other one then what's in
that box we don't know
you know so if the input is not correct
it's wrong then the result output is not
going to be correct
how can you
do a forensic audit when you cannot
verify all this as an observer
there i was there and to be honest with
you i have no clue what to look for as i
walk in there myself i'm in the first
week the visibility on the screen you
cannot see anything it's chaotic in
there
it's zigzag all over the place you
cannot see anything
so
this change of custody is a it's an
issue that we need to support this bill
to make it clear and i've attended right
after november election i've attended
helping with the recall of one or two of
the recalls and a few more right after
that
and you know those boxes of balance
sitting there
are piling on each other
the tape the red tape that you think
that if you open it will rip the thing
no you peel it open and you can just put
it right back over
so like what's the point of this red
tape that you put it over to seal
that you can just open like it's no seal
what's the point of those seals
right
and then in the bedford election
special election a few months ago i was
there trying to observe it
it's way at the end you cannot see and
only one guy
tried to like get all the balance out by
himself and do whatever in the back we
cannot see because way at the end by
himself
who watching all those things
do we know for sure if all the ballast
out of that box of that machine no and
then it went over to this table and then
some people go over there do something
box something put at the bottom at the
floor and then somebody else come over
and do that and they keep watching those
boxes because to me those are goals
whatever the result is we have to rely
on these boxes of balance to ensure that
we have the right result
but the change of custody of handling
the balance during the process is so
confusing there's no double checking and
i attended the very uh special election
that the tina was there and i said she's
doing a great job because you know what
she invited all the people the candidate
and media and the public to stand close
to as they get the balance out of the
machine and show to us is empty
you know so it's it's transparent
process whatever the result comes out we
accept that
winning or losing it doesn't matter it
matters that our vote does matter that's
what it's important that's why i'm here
and a majority of my friends that they
cannot make it to be here
we honor it together really and speaking
for
the face of the voters in our state
really we have no faith after november's
third election thank you ciao kelly so
you're in support of this bill
definitely okay thank you thank you so
much
and it's are there any questions from
committee members representative
prudhommer brian thank you thank you for
being here thank you for
watching this process so as much as you
have and bringing more attention to this
process
have you been able to
watch the process of the boxes being
sealed the ballot boxes being sealed in
your own community during elections in
your own community and how did that go
um
i'm in media so on election day i'm
usually running all over the places to
cover them
okay and i go and help people go to vote
i on 20 something years i always ask
people go register vote and help them to
go vote so i'm all over the places so i
cannot attend my local town but i attend
a republican meeting recently and we've
learned from the republican party that
we
can have two
uh it's called
ballet um inspector or something like
that challenger
the party can appoint a two person that
we can go inside the ring
this bill has to do with transport of
boxes after the election so that's what
we need to focus on so yeah so i
couldn't observe that catherine thank
you okay thank you any further questions
from committee members
not seeing any things thank you thank
you for your time also signed up to
speak is
secretary scanlon for information
purposes
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlon secretary of
state and
i i would just like to say on this piece
of legislation that it it really goes to
the heart of probably the biggest
problem that we have facing elections
now and that is
trying to get a handle on the decline in
voter confidence in the election
process
and to reestablish that we are going to
have to take steps
to make sure that
the general public the voters in our
state can understand
how we are protecting and preserving
ballots
after the election is over
uh to their satisfaction so that they
can have faith in the process
we do have chain of custody with ballots
at the current time
it certainly is not perfect
we train local election officials on
that process
but we also have a very high turnover
on a regular basis with election
officials
and they have to learn these things as
they as they come on board
those of you that have attended recounts
and have seen the boxes of ballots that
we are going to count
at a recount
have the red security tape on them
probably 80 of them maybe more are are
properly sealed as we train them but
there is al always a percentage of boxes
that don't quite
meet the standard that
that we would like to see at an election
some of the ways that we can resolve
that and and i think we are going to
implement this is just have spot visits
on a regular basis basis
hitting as many town clerks as possible
where we or the attorney general's
office or both of us just show up
unannounced and ask to see
how these materials are being stored
and we can grade them on that and and
help them
address any deficiencies
that might be out there
the other part of this is that you know
we are not afraid to store all of these
materials
at the state archives but i can tell you
that that would be a monumental process
to make happen and
whenever we go out now and collect
ballots from the municipalities for a
recount
and and we bring in a lot of boxes even
though it's a
relatively small percentage of the
ballots that may have been used
statewide
number one we make sure that the boxes
are properly sealed
number two is that we put a barcode
on each box and identify the contents so
that we can keep track of those boxes
once they leave the clerk's office and
we receive them
at the archives and store them on
shelves
that allows us to be able to go back and
retrieve those boxes when the time for
the recount comes
to
have a provision in the statute where
within 48 hours
all
materials associated with the election
have to be delivered to the archives
is
just an unreal unrealistic
expectation
i would need the national guard i think
to pull that off and and even then it
would be difficult
um
one of the
persons that testified earlier talked
about
the destruction of absentee ballots that
are received by the clerk
in a federal election
which would be our state elections have
to be preserved for a period
of 22 months
and in the case of absentee ballots when
they are rejected and receiving them
after the deadline is a reason for
rejection we have to actually record
those
in election net and the voters
themselves can actually look up
on our website
the status of their absentee ballot
and they should be able to see that it
was received after the election
and that it was not counted because it
was rejected for that purpose
but bottom line is i believe the federal
law applies
uh to preserving those ballots for 22
months
and then the third issue
and the sponsor said that it wasn't his
intent
to require the permanent preservation of
those ballots but if we can't destroy
them after the 22-month period and after
all
you know legal issues have been settled
with any recounts or appeals or anything
like that
that if we're unable to destroy those
ballots then
they're just going to sit around and you
know even though we
recently put a new addition on the
archives we have plenty of space now but
i can tell you
um
during an election cycle we would we
would bring in
it could be as many as 5 000 boxes
per election cycle and that space will
fill up in a hurry
and
you know we'll have to
look at other alternatives
bottom line i think that this is a is a
discussion that we need to have and i
think that there are things that we can
do
relative to chain of custody that will
certainly help
the general public understand the
process better and have more confidence
in how that process works
and i would be happy to answer any
questions questions from the committee
for secretary scanlon
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you very much thank you for being here
and uh
i like what you said about
doing spot visits and checking how boxes
are prepared by local officials can we
talk about the november 2020
general election
and
in general what grade would you give to
election officials throughout the state
and what grade would you give to windham
election officials for how they prepared
boxes in the november 2020 general
election
well
some towns and cities do better than
others and
and uh
if i had to put
put a grade to that statewide
it would probably be a b
um
windham had their issues
and
you know i don't know that the issues
are necessarily systemic in in windham
you know we're looking at one election
and we're looking at an election that
was really unique in many ways
and i think the primary reason for
issues the towns have had
in 2020 is the direct result
of the volume of absentee ballots
that we had to deal with um in the case
of windham i mean they took a shortcut i
think they thought it was okay and you
know i think that their
their intentions were sincere but they
decided to use a letter folding machine
to
full balance and that's what caused the
problem with the oval
you know it was it was a measure that
was taken to deal with
the high volume of ballots in the case
of bedford
they had a huge volume of absentee
ballots
higher than the state average
and
and they just lost track of a of a
stack of
absentee ballots
and unfortunately that stack did not get
counted and
you know the the
issues that developed out of that you
know are what they are but um
you know if it was a normal election i
don't know that we would have seen the
same issues uh that we saw as a result
of 2020
which was difficult because of the
pandemic
further question
well uh
i appreciate your diplomacy and
towards the town of windham and their
officials but i've been watching this
for a while and i saw those boxes come
out of windham and
would you agree that it's not crazy to
say that that grade would be an f
raise it as a question the grade would
have been lower than the the state
average yeah thank you thank you very
much
always diplomatic mr scott the teacher
every parent wants grading their child's
work representative barry
congratulations secretary scan that was
a very political answer um
for the record i would give windham an f
minus
um but to my point of question and to my
point my question at the beginning you
said voter integrity is going to be a
very high priority for your office i
cannot express to you how
happy that makes me
we have an issue i've spoken to that
issue several times
you said in your testimony
that part of those integrity measures
that we're going to take to get people
comfortable voting again
is going to be looking at things like
this and you said
not necessarily this bill but things
concerning ballot custody you talked
about spot checking was that what you're
referring about other measures or are
there are there other measures that your
office is considering um concerning
custody and and would it would it be
helpful if this
committee used this bill as a vehicle
for those for those
for those if they exist those other
measures
i think this bill would be very
appropriate
for
continuing to work on those measures
spot checks
is certainly part of that
there are different types of security
seals that are out there and maybe we
can
do better with you know having something
that
you know that will
give confidence that you know once the
boxes are closed after
the election is over that you know they
haven't been opened and and somehow
tampered with
right now we use red security tape um
that tape is designed so that if it's
lifted it shouldn't stick again when
it's laid back down
but also leaves an ink residue
on the box
you know to show that
you know the tape had moved somehow
sometimes that tape gets
gets
disturbed just in the process of
handling boxes
and
you know if that happens then it does
create doubt in a person that's looking
at that
box we are we are in the process now of
designing
uh different types of boxes to put
different types of election materials in
so
you know one set of boxes might have
cast ballots in it another set of boxes
would have absentee voting materials in
it another set of boxes might have
uncast ballots
that were used in the election just to
keep things separate we also want to
make sure that that we start
keeping boxes
for each ballot counting device
separate and so that they're all all
blended together
so if we can identify a problem that
might be unique to one machine
that you know we can go to that set of
ballots and try and resolve
what the issues are
yeah so i think there's a there's a
number of tools that we can use number
strategies and and we're open to
suggestions
further questions representative
thank you madam chair and uh also
congratulations secretary scanlan
um
you had mentioned earlier that
when when you boxes come in for a
recount that 80 percent roughly 80
percent of the boxes
have proper chain of custody procedures
whether ceiling or labeling or whatever
is that correct
yeah don't hold me to the eighty percent
the point i was trying to make is it you
know that there most of the boxes are
are properly
dealt with and it's a direct result of
the training that we do with local
election officials
but there are always
a percentage of boxes that come in
that that don't meet the standard um and
whenever we pick the boxes up and
whenever there's a recount we always
send our staff out with a state van
to go out and pick the boxes up we will
number one make sure that the box is
secure so that there aren't any loose
flaps where things can fall out of or be
slipped in
and then once they're secure we put a
barcode label on them so that we can
identify that box
we put it on a log so that when it
leaves the clerk's office the clerk
signs off on it and then when it's
received at the state archives the state
archivist or the records manager will
sign off that we've actually received
those boxes so we have an inventory
uh
identified by barcode and then a and
then a
and then a listing of what the contents
are supposed to be in each box
um that's the basic process it has
worked all these years but i think we
can enhance it and and make it more
secure
thank you and follow up for another
question
and i appreciate that clarification i i
i understand that the eighty percent is
sort of an estimate but it it was an
estimate that concerns me greatly
because
twenty percent
not having complete and accurate chain
of custody is a lot if it's 10 it's a
lot and so i i appreciate
some of the procedures you're talking
about i commend you for that and uh and
the spot checks
i think are extremely important and um
i have voice to you personally and i'll
say this publicly that if there is
additional funding needed for the
secretary of state's office i'm willing
to fight for it
thank you
representative lane
thank you madam chair and i'll add my
congratulations
um
when you said you supported the bill it
was with the amendments i just want to
make clear that you would that this
measure but with the changes that you
discussed i don't know
that he said he supported the bill okay
he did not say that all right so
could you correct
that for me so that i understand it
better yeah i i did not support the bill
i'm here to offer information i i think
that the subject matter that the bill
addresses is something that we need to
have a conversation about okay
thank you for that clarification okay
representative pimento
thank you madam chairman uh thank you
secretary of state and congratulations
um
simple question what is within
your power
as secretary of state
to make adjustments to the chain of
custody
and
what would be required from the
legislature
i think any any record-keeping
uh
that we do
in terms of receiving
the the election materials and
delivering them
to the archives
is something that we can establish
procedures for
for example i i don't think that there's
anything that would prevent us
after we put the barcodes on them and
make sure that they're secure from
taking photographs of every box just so
that we have a record of that i mean i
think that's
i think that's something that we could
do without legislation um
i think things in the bill about
requiring
all boxes to be delivered
to the state archives for storage is
something that would require
legislation right now the statutes
only say that we bring boxes to the
archives of ballots for when a recount
is requested so that we can
conduct that recount
otherwise
the ballots and other election materials
stay in the clerk's office and they have
to store them for the 22 months and then
they can destroy them now i'm not aware
of any clerks that would be unhappy if
we had to give those boxes to the state
because it does it does open up space
for them
further questions from the committee no
that's good thank you very much
representative growing are you all set
any further questions
um
thank you i i would like to say to this
the secretary that the windham letter
that we referred to
uh made me mindful of the fact that much
of what is covered by rules for other
departments is in statute
for
the election duties of the secretary of
state's office and i was actually quite
grateful for that
in
reading
that report because
i believe that it makes it easier to
discern on on
the conduct of elections as to what is
permissible and not additionally it
makes
the changing of things a subject to
a process that has a much more public
picture to it
and
i suspect is easier for you on the other
hand
i have been to the clerk trainings and
i don't want to overwhelm
the statute procedural piece with what
your office needs to be responsive to
when you get asked questions at those
trainings as to how to handle particular
things because our voting
areas the 200 plus
areas that we have that conduct
elections are very different
so when you say we need to have a
conversation i appreciate that because
i don't think you want to constrain
everything as you said 48 hours for some
of these communities to do anything with
ballots after election
is going to
be a vastly different
use of resources from one community to
the next so
thank you
up see there you go i the lawyer kept
talking and now we've got more
representative growing
i'm not a lawyer but i'll
follow up on that
what is what is the level of uniformity
and and control
at the local level
for storage of the ballots once that
once they are boxed and sealed
it varies widely from community to
community it just depends on what type
of facilities
they have and i can tell you the
the uniformity has come a long way
within the last 20 years
and a lot of that was brought on by the
help america vote act which required
the state to
you know have uniformity
with things like the voter
database
prior to that every town or city
maintain their own checklist on whatever
software program they had available some
actually still had them
hand written
but you know as you can imagine the
city of manchester or nashua probably
have vaults
where they can
you know put put these documents but you
know if you go up to colebrook
you know it might be the you know might
be the broom closet that you know the
clerk can just turn the key um
if they have if they have that and
so um
the the training is that
the boxes have to be properly sealed
the seals that are placed on the boxes
have to be
signed by the appropriate election
officials and you have to store them
in a secure location
and then it's left up to the local
community on just exactly what that
means but you know i think the spot
checking idea is one that uh you know
might be able to help
in that regard in terms of uh
you know we do have vital records in our
division and and of course there's a lot
more money that is generated through
the documents that the clerks have to
produce but
we were able to take some of that money
and give grants
to the cities and towns
for
for better storage of their vital
records information
and some of them were able to take that
and you know design you know appropriate
storage you know get things out of the
basement and
and things like that and maybe something
like that as uh you know we're trying
with election materials
follow-up follow-up uh
you
you implied that
you don't necessarily think it's a good
idea to bring all the ballots to concord
uh
what what are your thoughts on that do
you think they're better left at the
community level or uh would it be better
to
have a state storage facility for all
these boxes i think as long as the
election materials are stored
in a box or container that is
tamper evident
and
that they have secure storage that
that there's no reason why we cannot
continue to
you know let the storage be in the
communities
um
i think they have to be able to show
that
you know that their storage and the way
they're handling those is
uh
is sound insecure for transparency
um
you know but i think there's i think
there is a way that we can
make that happen
thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you secretary scanlon
that is the last speaker i have signed
up for 1457. we did have persons sign up
with a position remotely
four persons
show
signed up in support of it 21 persons
signed up opposed to it
and we had three persons sign up here in
the lob two of them did not speak and
they were in favor of the bill
that concludes all the input that i have
on 1457
i will close the public hearing and this
committee is now in recess for lunch our
next uh event begins at one o'clock and
that will be a hearing on hb 1522.
okay
all right good afternoon everyone it is
still thursday january 20th it is one
o'clock somewhere
so we are going to start our afternoon
hearings the first bill that this
committee has scheduled for this
afternoon
is hb
1522 this is requiring the use of
ballots with embedded security and
relative to the chain of custody of
absentee ballots
and we have with us to
introduce a bill to committee
representative abrami the prime sponsor
welcome representative
thank you madam chair
uh for
for the record uh state rep pattabrami
rockingham 19 stratum
and we we've
i've left my testimony on the table
and there's another document with some
pictures on it that's one of the other
speakers also left
her her stuff on the table as well
this bill is about security and and
chain of custody of ballots
with all the concerns surrounding
election integrity this bill suggests
some straightforward ways in which all
voters can feel even more confident
about our election integrity
if the state were a bank
or other business that relied on utmost
security and accuracy of information
we as a state would have most likely
adopted these types of practices long
ago madam chair
a new poll conducted by ipsos
just a couple of weeks ago actually and
published in by abc news this month
reaffirms that we already know what we
already know
that americans faith in the integrity of
election system remains shake
shaken with only 20 percent of the
public saying is very confident about
the system
this is a citizen-wide issue
irrespective of party
70 of democrats 80 of independents and
87 percent of republicans
do not feel very confident in the
election process
we need to address
that that with some fundamentals
here in new hampshire
new hampshire plays a very unique role
in the country we are first in the
nation and with this responsibility we
should be best in class in our election
practices
this bill
we are bringing forward is to straighten
out controls and increase process
transparency
this will result in improving the
integrity of the election process
and instilling confidence in our
election results
to our citizens and country
i want to pause here and just say
i have no
our former secretary of state very well
and he's probably the man of the most
integrity in this in the state house for
so many years
and he did a great job all those years
but i think now we're in 2000 and
you know we're in the 21st century now
in terms of technology i think we can
improve
upon some of our technology that we're
using so the
the
the bill addresses four areas first is
the upgrade of ballot technology
with the growth of absentee ballots it
is imperative we upgrade our ballot
technology and make this part of our dna
this includes review and recommendation
of improvements every five years by the
secretary of state's office
in addition this bill would upgrade our
paper ballots to include
watermarked paper magnetic inks and
other available tools to limit
counterfeit ballots
second thing it addresses it's the
tightening of the business controls
we should centralize design and supply
selection of ballot printing with the
secretary of state nag
we should strictly manage the number of
ballots issued and unissued by with
towns ballots should
be reconciled before and after the
election with every ballot accounted for
we
we should use separation of duties with
towns managing the ordering and storage
of ballots
and envelopes while the the secretary of
state manages the supplier and the
and the recounts
and finally
absentee ballots
that do not meet the residency or
identification requirements of rsa 657
colon 7
roman 2
will have a time to cure
the voter will be notified by the clerk
of deficiencies
the voter will have up to the close of
the polls to cure
after the election
or
the vote
that that was rejected and then if if
not cured the vote would have to be
rejected
the third major area is increased ballot
security
ballots should be stored in locked
encrypted storage
areas with access controls implemented
including video surveillance and and
access logs
and the final issue uh is transparency
we should allow the public viewing of
digital copies of the ballots uh
processed
to enable citizen audit within eight
hours of of uh the close of the polls
madam chair
i'm sure the committee will review each
component of this bill and support the
whole or pieces that
uh you deem the most feasible to adopt
the work on this bill was researched by
a group led by brenda towne who was here
today and will be testifying
and i hope after the
reps and senators speak that you bring
her up next because she's the one who
has the answers to your questions
so please defer to her
and in addition
i just found out that i have to be back
in ways it means to open up the one
o'clock yep that's fine who did you ask
that you wanted to testify next
representative uh brenda towne okay
although we have one other rep that
wants to testify soon all right i just
wanted to make sure that okay thank you
madam chair and thank you committee okay
thank you
given his need to leave i'm not going to
ask the committee if they have any
questions also signed up to speak on
this is brendatown
uh well i just asked representative
abrami who we wanted to go next
representative
are you did you
are you good okay
sorry
there you go
well thank you very much i wanted to be
respectful and um thank you madam chair
thank you committee for hearing me today
um
as uh i may have met you guys last week
yeah i spoke and so you know i'm a
military mom and i'm a grandma and i ran
a business here in new hampshire i was
the controller of a of a large division
of hewlett-packard and um i today manage
an operations unit for a contract
manufacturer so i got this kind of crazy
background and it helps inform me of all
the different things that
raised a passion in me and election has
become that passion and as pat
representative obrami said to you guys i
started working with a large group of
citizens to do a citizen's audit
on the state after the uh 2020 election
because we wanted to see how we were
doing and so as part of that effort
we've got about 7 000
folks who follow us on multiple
platforms in social media and contribute
to the work that we are doing to perform
the audit we've done about 243 foia
requests
in order to gather information we have
the machine tapes on pretty much every
town and we've done a lot of work with
the towns
on pulling their information and helping
them understand the information
and what i really wanted to say is that
i want the clerks and the townsfolks to
know that we appreciate everything that
they do
in no way it coming to check a process
are we saying that there's something
that anyone's doing wrong instead
the more work we do the more we really
appreciate the level of effort and
integrity that the teams have and so we
brought this bill forward because we
really believe process improvement
which is what we do in manufacturing
would really help our town team and one
of those areas of process improvement is
segregation of responsibilities and
improving the security of things
so i wanted to just talk to you a little
bit about our responsibility of making
sure that our election um our votes and
ballots are treated like cash i think we
would all appreciate having that level
of rigor and also the importance of us
being first in the nation we have a lot
of people watching what we do and we set
the tone for the rest of the elections
rolling through so we take that real
seriously
so what we found through our process is
that we have ballots that are printed by
our towns
and are managed by our towns
i actually personally printed my son's
military ballot and mailed it to him at
camp lejeune and had him mail it in and
so through the process what we found is
that the printing of ballots is really
inconsistent across our state different
papers different ways of accessing the
ballots um people are using the town
printers or even going to staples so
from an integrity standpoint we really
don't have one standard on how we print
those ballots as well as we have no way
as a state to recognize whether all the
ballots went out were all the ones that
came back in we can't reconcile that and
if that was your bank account you'd be a
little bit nervous that um they couldn't
tell you where the money went and so we
were asking on this bill to increase the
security of the ballots themselves as
well as the process in which we manage
them
we're also looking for
increased security on the storage of
those ballots and included on the
handout that i gave you are pictures of
the ballots that were splashed all over
the news when the wyndham um town was
audited and you'll notice there's just
giant gaps and plastic in um
in paper boxes in tape has been sealed
and unsealed and
and so from an overall security
standpoint we really are lacking in that
space and we owe it to the citizens of
new hampshire to treat their ballots as
though they had just done a deposit in
the bank so if anything ever needs an
audit we have that source material
i wanted to talk to you a little bit
about canvassing and what we found in
canvassing so i led the canvassing
efforts
and again some high-level stats are
there we haven't completed our work
we're still
we're almost done but i wanted to show
the committee that these are all signed
affidavits from people who have gone out
to
canvas our towns and what we've found on
average of the people who answered the
door 15
of those folks didn't actually cast the
ballot
so it's there's a gap and so what we're
asking the committee to do is to help us
in this one area to close the gap on
ballot security and that involves both
the as i said the printing of them and
giving them out to our citizens as well
as the way that we store them when we
get them back
the last part of this bill that is
really urgent is the transparency aspect
from somebody who went and helped the
team do the citizens audit
what we found is disconnects in a lot of
the data that we collected what was on
the secretary of state's database was
not the same thing that the towns had
and unfortunately we had no visibility
into the ballots to triangulate all that
stuff and i know that there was a huge
turnout last week of people concerned
truly concerned about our voting
machines and to provide this
transparency of all of the ballots that
were processed
that would enable a citizen to complete
this audit and would
allow us to have a level of confidence
that the whole process could be tightly
managed i'm sure there are more things
to address but i looked at this as an
opportunity to set some of the macro
level business controls in place and to
create a corrective action and
continuous improvement process which is
what we do in manufacturing so thank you
very much and if you have any questions
i'd be glad to answer them for you thank
you for your testimony questions
from the committee
representative
hit groin right button thank you
um
so
one of the changes in here is
um
to have the it
previously it said ballots uh shall be
prepared and delivered by the secretary
of state now it says ordered by
political subdivision from deployer
supplier determined by the secretary of
state why that change
so what we were trying to do is again
separation of duties so the secretary of
state would have the responsibility of
the design and the selection
of the supplier in the ballots
the towns would then be responsible for
ordering their total quantity and being
able to measure the amount of ballots in
amount of ballots used amount of ballots
left over and the supplier would act as
kind of that pivot point in the middle
uh managing the overall flow of ballots
so that they could provide that
reconciliation of who got what ballot
and so again keeping it at the source
was the idea
follow up madam chair follow up so
would would the ballots be
individually identified by some bar code
or would it just be by number of ballots
that each
voting
area
received
so there's two ways right the design
which would be up to the secretary of
state and a.g to create
could have some kind of qr code which
some other states are recommending to
allow the voter to watch their vote go
through the process
in this we left it open so that the
secretary of state could determine if we
would use pure ballot count as our
message our method to reconcile or
whether there would be more complex
technology introduced into these ballots
at this point in time a step a major
step forward would be the total
reconciliation of ballots where they
went and where they remain
at the end of an election
thank you
further questions from the committee
representative
thank you madam chair thank you man for
taking the question
has this been used in any other state or
has this been or in a business uh format
in other words is this technology been
been tried and tested yet
um it's being introduced in arizona as
we speak and i don't know if there are
other states that are using it today i
know that other states do use a
different methodology to trace their
ballots so that they do know how many
have been sent out and how many they've
gotten returned but that's a gap in our
process so it would be something that as
a state this methodology
would help us to close and it would also
help us with the authenticity of the
ballots that are being processed
thank you and um what would you envision
the time frame would be to
if
we wanted to go down this path to
implement
the change over for all the items listed
in the bill
well i would anticipate that this would
take probably a year for the
process to be validated and then there's
obviously going to be some level of
design for those ballots and then
training for our teams so that they feel
confident in the process so i'd give it
a year
from the date it said okay if and that's
if from the business world i don't know
the legislative world i know that in my
world we'd i'd give them three months
but i don't know what we give them here
further questions from the committee
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
um one of the things you said in your
testimony is that
towns and cities are ordering ballots
from all different vendors and coming up
in different types of paper
state elections the ballots are prepared
under the supervision of the secretary
of state from a local printer with
oversight provided by the secretary of
state can you explain why it would be
more efficient to now have more than 200
cities and towns dealing with a single
vendor instead of one office dealing
with a single vendor well i believe that
this gives the flexibility to the towns
to manage the total count of votes
and what i've seen in the
election
audit that we've done is that towns
would order their ballots from that
location and then they would go out if
they were short and print them on their
printers within their own town halls or
run down to staples and that just
happened in greenland a couple weeks ago
and it was very public
follow up
follow up um again i
it sounds like you're talking about town
elections but i'll move on to another
question okay um
on page two
all ballots received shall after
inspection be stored in locked boxes and
encrypted there's a cost associated with
that who's going to pay for it the
constitution says that the legislature
can't uh pass unfunded mandates and so
how much is it going to cost who's going
to pay for it where's the funds going to
come from
well that's why we're going to go to the
finance committee to do an assessment of
the costs and at this point in time um
talking to pat abrami we're assuming
that there would be a fund created to
relieve the costs to the towns from the
state level okay no further questions
manager
further questions from the community i
had one more comment um
in in total
i believe that the angst in the number
of foia requests that are being launched
against our towns
has grown because of this concern over
business controls so
when i assess kind of the overall cost
benefit of this bill
there may be cost increases in one area
but i i believe that there will be
reductions in other areas and as you can
see demonstrated in the pictures of the
windham audit and the conditions of the
security that were used to store those
ballots i think that the folks here in
new hampshire would be very anxious and
willing to fund the improvement thank
you thank you
further questions from the committee
representative growing
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
on page four
the the last item on you the electronic
ballot counting devices
and it you're adding to have a
digital scan
uh made
do you have more
you have thoughts on that as to how
would that be accomplished is that to be
done centrally or to be done by the city
and down or how would that be done it
could be done very simply with the town
a simple scanner along with a connection
to a storage device would be able to
house those images and at the end of an
election it could be uploaded to the
town website
you would just need the capability of a
high speed scanner
thank you
further questions from the committee
representative
i'm drawing it blank i have a blank
representative ward go ahead
you're too far away from me
thank you for taking my question um i
just had a question about your
uh canvassing preliminary findings you
went through that kind of quickly and i
wonder if you can can you get a little
closer to the mic we're just having to
explain the canvassing procedure you did
and what that you think that actually
meant
so um the canvassing
first i'd like to say that anybody who
went canvassing my hats off to them
because nobody
all the introverts in the world ran in
the other direction when we sent out a
request but what the canvassing was like
is we took the actual town
checklists from the day of the election
and we created walk lists to make it
easier to find folks who voted in
neighborhoods and then we would go knock
on a door and ask them the people at the
home hey um are you judy smith and have
them confirm who they were um and then
we would ask if they voted in the
election if there were other folks in
their household that voted and
if there were other voters they might
come and participate in the canvas or
judy might answer for her spouse but we
went door-to-door to door-to-door and we
did almost
900 houses so far and i haven't gotten
the rest of the results in yet
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you and
i'm sorry i missed some of your
testimony
but
are you talking about people that voted
absentee and then you found that 15 of
them did not return their absentee
ballot
um no there's
all kinds of different scenarios that
were we're doing the analysis on but
what would happen is i'd knock on a door
and i would ask the person hey um is
marge you know smith here and
she'd say that's me and i said i would
ask her did you vote in the 2020
election we're just doing a canvas and
she would say no i didn't vote in the
election but then town checklist said
that marge smith voted absentee and that
would be one of the items that we would
create an affidavit for
questions from the committee
representative
i'm just curious um
when you said you hit 900 homes over the
course of the state i mean it's a huge
amount did you target a certain
community in particular and if so why
we actually we used two smaller towns
because we thought that we would be able
to
get a better sense of the overall town
and we targeted um two towns that had
a higher
level of turnout relative to their
overall registration because we felt
that maybe there was something that was
a little unusual in those towns and so
we started there with the vast
uh state and a small team we just had to
pick our bets and choose two towns that
we thought we would be able to see if
there were issues with
all set for the question
representative barry
so i am a little confused here um
because
if if i'm hearing you correctly it's
it's uh we have a problem
you would go to the door you would talk
to them they would say i didn't vote in
the election and then they would sign
the affidavit the piece of paper um
that's a you weren't here for my
affidavit speech but uh they would sign
the piece of paper
and
saying i did not vote in the election
and that's what you have with you today
no i have the canvassers
affidavits who are testifying to they
went to that person's door and what the
person said to them i have the name of
the voter their address how the record
said that they voted in what the voter
told us so those are all contained in
the affidavits and i'm sorry ma'am
follow up and do you intend to provide
that list to the committee the secretary
of state's office or the department of
justice yes we will we're just as i said
unfortunately the timing of all of these
things
and trying to close on it but i will be
providing all of that and uh and provide
the analysis that s at the top level as
well
further questions
representative lane
thank you madam chair and thank you
um
i want to follow up on representative
bergeron's question because i'm still
confused on
how having the towns and the cities
print the ballots
make it it doesn't seem to me that it's
adding that much more control or i mean
why isn't it but
or why is there a problem with the way
it's done now
so um today what we're seeing is that
towns can augment their um ballots by
supplementing them with additional
prints of ballots and there's a lack of
consistency
on the overall
ballot construction the paper the ink
the format where they came from and the
total number
so what we're trying to do is say look
we've found this supplier supplier x who
is going to be the sole source for all
of our ballots
you know uh manchester will order all
their ballots from that supplier and
then those ballots will come directly to
manchester in manchester will manage
their ballots
that supplier will then have visibility
in how
the total number of ballots that were
issued across the state of new hampshire
so we have data point one
then we have the data point of
manchester and then all the other towns
how many times how many ballots did they
issue absentee how many ballots did they
use the day of the election for
in-person voting and how many were not
used at the end of this process we can
tie all of the numbers together to see
how many total ballots were used in all
of those capacities and whether they tie
out to what that supplier issued and so
what we're trying to do is just
triangulate the control so that we know
that there aren't any um access ballots
out into the
citizens re to people that may not or
should not be voting in our elections
does that make sense
that process makes sense i guess what i
don't what i'm missing and maybe this is
my own lack of knowledge is how is it
done now from the secretary of state
do they
just ship them to manchester or
just me so maybe that's what i'm missing
i don't know how it's done now and where
there's a a gap
and you know for
it is my understanding that the gap
today is that not only do they get the
ballots from the secretary of state but
they are also supplementing with
additional ballots should they need them
in order to conduct their elections all
right i need a little specificity in
terminology because when you use the
term there and for those of us who are
familiar with the procedure there are
specific parties involved in this
process who do this the secretary of
state is not supplementing ballots on a
local level that is something handled by
local officials under a procedure that
is governed under
uh processes that they receive training
from from the secretary of state
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair actually you kind
of addressed the point i was going to
make the only times or did you know that
the only times that cities or towns are
authorized under state law to print
additional ballots is when they run out
of the ballots provided by the secretary
of state's office for state elections
and that that there are
very high standards for them to meet and
it's very very rare that this ever
occurs you're making it sound like this
happens all the time in all the cities
and towns and that's just not true
um i don't want it and i apologize that
wasn't a question all right i don't want
to cast dispersions on anyone i'll just
tell you from my personal experience
that at for the last presidential
election i printed on my home printer
so for the last presidential election
you're talking about the absentee ballot
process is that correct yes and did you
actually print a ballot or did you print
an absentee ballot request i printed the
ballot okay
and were those processes established as
a one-time procedure for that election
if you know i have no idea i just again
as somebody who's collecting all of the
moving parts and trying to see if we
could put some more business controls in
place to that that was a reaction to
that issue
representative hayward
uh thank you madam chairman thank you
and
your
answer earlier
i have trouble making this a question
um
the military ballots
that their
procedure
is you get an email
you print
the pdf from the email you fill that out
and mail it in
that's a yukaba ballot and i understood
her to just say that was an absentee
ballot so can we have some clarification
was it it was a ballot or an absentee it
was a military ballot okay so there are
completely different federal rules
governing you cava ballots continue
representative hayward
procedurally
if we're going to have watermarked
ballots
how would that work
it would be my understanding that we
would
send ballots to locations where our
personnel are in order to provide them
or in the case of military ballots if
that's an impossibility that we would
make
a process for them to be able to
participate in the vote
for those people
listening who don't know what a youkava
ballot is that's a special provision
under
a federal statute to allow deployed
military personnel to participate in an
election and there are actually
separate as you've just heard separate
procedures and actually certain
deadlines that need to be met
in order
to ensure that deployed military service
people can receive a ballot in time for
it to be counted in the election just
for clarification
further questions from committee members
representative go ahead
thank you madam chairman
my question is related to
a couple of things
either one the town didn't order enough
ballots
or maybe they ordered them too late
how would that be dealt with
for the voters of that town
well i
again as a practice
we would probably in tell our towns to
order over what they would anticipate
for voters to in order to be able to
accommodate with the idea being that
they would have leftovers in in every
condition
i don't know the best method if they ran
out in my world of manufacturing we call
that safety stock and we would hold
extra in reserve in anticipation that
there was more of a turnout than we had
historically seen
follow-up question can you please get
closer to the mic we've gotten a comment
that people are not getting picked up
um
so
if that all goes wrong
and a particular town doesn't have
more ballots
is there
i i mean we have people who want to vote
we don't want to disenfranchise them
that's true
what would be the procedure
for the town to get more ballots
on the day of the election
i would i would if i were trying to
solution it on the day of i would be
finding out if other towns had excess
ballots that could be used in my town
ballot in my time elections that's what
i would do
if
there was a shortage but again i would
also create a process where there was a
safety stock and reserve level
that each town would hold in
anticipation of
an increase in turnout from their
historical performance
that's the way that we handle it in my
world as i said
all set
further questions from members of the
committee
i'm not seeing any thank you for coming
all right thank you so much and i really
appreciate it i wish i had every answer
in the planet i don't i'm only just a
passionate citizen who
is hoping for some help thank you
representative aaron
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee
i appreciate you hearing my testimony
today
as a co-sponsor of this bill
i'm asking that you support hb 1522 this
bill requires that elections in new
hampshire be conducted oh i'm sorry for
the record representative judy aaron i
represent sullivan county district 7.
so this bill requires that elections in
new hampshire be conducted using ballots
with embedded security and specifies
security upgrades for ballot chain of
custody during and after an election
this bill also requires validation of
the eligibility of absentee ballot
voters this bill improves layers of
security for our elections which is a
positive step in maintaining trust in
the election process
first of all
embedded security placed in our printed
ballots maintains the integrity of the
voting process by ensuring that only
authentic ballots are used during an
election
embedded security features can prevent
the unauthorized generation printing
duplication or counterfeiting of ballots
for use in an election and therefore can
prevent counterfeit ballots from being
counted as valid ballots
just like we embed our money with
watermarks and other measures to ensure
validity and authenticity we should do
the same with our election ballots
if we have this technology available
then why would we not employ it to
ensure election integrity
ballot security features could include
but are not limited to technology such
as ultraviolet features infrared
features magnetic features
fluorescence features
visual ink features and watermarks
the implementation of such features in
paper stock used to print official
ballots can also include but is not
limited to shapes words numbers images
barcodes codes and barcodes that can
include any one of real data and
encrypted real data
for example if the embedded feature is
magnetic such as an embedded metallic
layer the embedded metallic material can
have a particular shape
including the shape of a number a letter
or a word or be in the form of a bar
code
the ballot reader or machine tabulator
can read or sense the embedded security
feature while tabulating the choices
marked on the ballot and if the ballot
is not authentic then the ballot would
be rejected
secondly
with regard to ballot chain of custody
all ballots should be kept in
receptacles which have tamper-proof
seals and stored in secured places with
video monitoring
no on
unauthorized person should ever have
access to our election ballots while
they are being stored
currently i've seen that our ballots are
kept in taped up boxes
tape is not secure it can be ripped off
and replaced
we need more security in our chain of
custody for our elections the bill
addresses those security failings
lastly
anyone voting with an absentee ballot
needs to be thoroughly vetted and we
must make sure they are valid new
hampshire voters meeting residency and
identification requirements
this bill ensures that votes of absentee
ballots are not only counted if proper
are only counted if proper id
requirements are met
that's just common sense
no one should be able to vote if they
are not legal and eligible voters in new
hampshire
our requirements to vote must be
respected and adhered to
otherwise why have election laws at all
one may say this would be a big expense
to municipalities to implement these
kinds of changes
i think the assurance of a valid
election is totally worth the price
our constituents are demanding election
and cure integrity loudly
and clearly
and we should listen to them
this bill makes our voting system more
secure and tamper-proof
and that is why we should be pursuing
so i ask you to please pass this bill
out of your committee with an otp
recommendation
thank you for listening to me today
thank you for coming representative
questions
representative
representative terozian
thank you madam chair thank you
representative aaron for taking the
question
so i'm assuming and
let me know if i'm wrong in order to
implement this technology
uh all the towns would have to have a
new
vote counting machines in order to read
the
um security measures the whether it be
watermark or embedded uh type security
would that would that be true
possibly depending on what kind of
technology is chosen to be on these
ballots um
it could be that
maybe before they're scanned they're you
know
put into some other sort of machine to
validate them before they're read so um
you know could be that
rather than replacing the entire scanner
you just get some other piece of
equipment that would validate the ballot
prior to
follow-up question would um
so would that
mean that towns that currently use paper
ballots would probably have to go to a
vote counting machine
i'm not sure i think that that's you
know part of the processes that would
have to be worked out
through the through the process of
after the bill was passed
thank you
further questions from committee
representative i have a couple questions
and it might have been more appropriate
for representative abrami but i knew he
had to leave so
um i'm going to ask you you mentioned
uh the the absentee ballot process
that's in this bill and i was a little
surprised to see it because the purpose
was clearly to do with security and and
sort of chain of custody and then we had
this absentee ballot provision sort of
put into it on page four
so my uh
would you believe do you know when
absentee ballot envelopes are opened
under law now for elections
and when is that that's
when the
either what that usually they there's a
day before
that's pre-processing and that was a
special process that was for the
elections of 2020 only
so currently there are no pre-processing
provisions in law
so do you know
when under current law
absentee ballots are opened in the
election i'm not aware
okay would you believe that is the day
of election okay all right and i'm i'm
keeping a look at my secretary of state
bobbing heads and representative
bergeron to make sure i've got this
right
um we really should sort of make bobble
head dogs and
that that would be pretty good if you if
you weren't a bobblehead
doll in election law that means you've
made it all right
so
the so the envelopes are actually not
opened until the day of the election so
the processing of the absentee ballots
can occur on election day and there are
provisions in regards to letting people
watch the process and checking them in
through the checklist on the day of
election
so
i understand this bill and and
i think maybe i'm asking this question
for you to relay to representative
abrami maybe to get back to me sure um
this bill then would provide that the
moderator opens the envelope on the day
of the election
and that's when the verification process
begins at least as to whether this is an
appropriate voter who has returned a
requested absentee ballot
and then and on i'm again i'm on page
four the bill
um
section 13 and paragraph two
um it relates to with the documentation
for proof of identity is not sufficient
there is going to be an opportunity to
essentially cure right by notifying the
voter
and letting the voter
bring whatever is needed down by the end
of the day so that their absentee ballot
can be
can be marked
is that what you understand this
provision to me yes well they have up
until the close of the polls on that day
right so the envelope is being opened in
the morning
so if the deficiency is discovered they
have until the close of the polls that
day to correct it under the this version
of the bill
yes but i would also assume that
when from the time that the person
submits their absentee ballot to
the town
uh and the time of the election
that there's a time there that you can
bring your information to the town clerk
to have everything verified ahead of
time
that's actually not the absentee ballot
process okay i just wanted to clarify
because i think what this says is
that
your envelope is opened the receipt of
the absentee ballot is recorded and as
long as the clerks are keeping up with
the system the absentee voter can
actually go on
line and and see that their absentee
ballot has been received but that ballot
is not processed until the day of the
election
so on the day of the election the outer
envelope would be opened
and then the verification process with
the match to the request and the
checklist would be done
and if there was a deficiency under this
bill what would happen is there would be
a
requirement
because it says the moderator shall
contact the voter in an attempt to to
cure
the deficiency
and so
my question is
did you ask any did the sponsors of the
bill inquire of anybody at the ag's
office as to whether they felt such a
quick turnaround for a deficiency cure
would be legally acceptable
and two
what would happen if the moderator
cannot contact the voter because
sometimes people are absent because
they're absentee voters so you're not
able to reach them right um
so
um
and i've apologized for
posturing those questions to you but
perhaps um well yes somebody else
speaking can address it or
representative abrami can get back to us
i think
that's something i i would uh defer to
representative abrami i don't know if he
had something in mind in particular to
address that
but
okay it was my thought
that
between the time that a person submits
their absentee ballot whether it's
opened or not
to the town clerk
that they can then provide
uh documentation necessary to prove that
they are a legal you know legal and
eligible voter okay thank you
further questions from the committee
representative lane
thank you madam chair thank you
representative um
and again this may not be appropriate
for you
it's a question about
section 14 about the electronic ballot
counting devices
um i guess my my question is
one well i have two questions so
bruce go ahead
i have that provision circled also okay
one is uh to provide within eight hours
is that did anybody talk and then the
term is used citizen's audit could you
explain and it's in quotes and not
defined
so could you
explain what a citizen's audit is and is
eight hours enough time for it to be
turned over
well
citizens should be able to
see whether or not
you know what what the counts of the
ballots
were after the election i would imagine
that
the information should be made available
to them
if they if they can um
if you don't have the answers we maybe
you can convey this so yeah those issues
i would imagine
that representative romney probably had
um you know more insight into what he
was seeking for that
thank you i mean sure if you'll have
that that'd be great thanks
thanks does anybody have any questions
representative hamer
i just have a question on page four
roman numeral two
if the moderator finds the absentee
voter has not included the photocopied
documentation
so we have to make a photocopy
of your documentations when you sign
that in
send that in to show where you
live your id your id and everything
usually with the absentee ballots
they're for people that are not able to
come out
a lot
and
i think it would be hard a hardship on
them
to have a photocopy of these
documentations
do you agree
i'm not sure i don't know you know what
people's situations are but certainly
you know there are a lot of people have
photocopiers at home and well and even
if they don't they're available in many
different places so i don't know i think
it's it's not an unreasonable ask
thank you
further questions from the committee
i'm seeing none thank you thank you i
appreciate it
um
this hearing has gone on i wanted to let
the sponsor speak i'm going to recognize
the secretary of state david scanlon as
um that will conclude the people who had
signed up prior to the initiation of
this hearing to speak um and um i'm
going to give the secretary of state all
the time needed to address this bill
and answer questions from the committee
and then i have a few people signed up
to speak where we're going to limit
testimony to about three minutes thank
you
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i'm david scanlon secretary of
state
appearing today in opposition to the
bill
but before i go into the reasons why
i would like to just piggyback on my
prior testimony
saying that this type of
legislation
is
is the result of a decline in voter
confidence in our elections
and we do need to take steps to correct
that
there are some
portions in this bill that talk about
reconciliation of
of ballots
watermarks or synthetic dna or things
like that i think that should all be
part of the discussion
if it helps improve that confidence and
i'm certainly willing to work with the
committee or others on what that might
look like
moving forward
the primary reason that i pose the bill
is because it decentralizes who's
responsible for conducting the election
and right now the buck stops with the
secretary of state and the secretary of
state is chosen by the legislature every
two years and if that person doesn't do
a good job
then you know they're they're free to
choose somebody else
who
can if you remove
the secretary of state's responsibility
for
uh preparing the ballots and
distributing them
in an election you're you're really
tying
that person's hands behind their back
um you if you are handing over
responsibilities to a vendor
who is simply
in the market to make a profit
they're not necessarily accountable to
anybody at that point except that they
do a
bad job they may lose business
the next time around
and then the other part of this is we
have
probably 230 give or take
voting jurisdictions whether they're
cities or towns
and so you're putting in the hands of
responsibility of those
couple hundred individuals to make
appropriate decisions related to
elections
that they currently do not have to make
right now the secretary of state
and and this should be made clear that
all the ballots that are produced in new
hampshire go through a uniform process
all state ballots are printed exactly
the same way
they're proof read that the column
rotations are
are you know made to
apply the appropriately to the elections
and there is a standard process for
making that happen
each polling place each of the of the
309 or 310 polling places have a unique
ballot for that election so you simply
if you're running out you can't call the
next town over and say hey you have some
balance you can spare that's not the way
it works each of those towns has a
unique ballot
for the election they're carefully
proofed
and
and there is a
significant process undertaken by the
state to make sure that
the ballots are accurate and uh and
they're properly just distributed to the
communities
um so that's the primary reason why i
oppose this bill is that to me it does
not make sense
if you want to make sure the job gets
done that you take the one person that's
accountable and you spread it out
to over over 200
entities to make that happen
to me that's a recipe for disaster and
and so i would discourage that
part of the process though i think is is
you know making sure the public
understands better what that process is
i mean i you know based on the testimony
that i have heard so far i think that
there is an education effort that we
need to do to make sure that individuals
in the state just know exactly how
our elections work and i'm certainly
willing to help people understand that
process
the only other thing that i'll mention
is it right now we do not have a ballot
counting device
in use in new hampshire that is able to
record digital images of ballots
so the proposal where they can be simply
put up quickly
after an election is over
uh
it just is not it's just not possible at
this point
the beltlock commission has recently
approved the use of a
uh a newer different model
ballot accounting device for use in the
town elections in milford uh coming up
and so we'll see where that goes
and whether they're more likely to
approve a device
for state elections moving forward
the one concern that i have about
posting digital images of ballots all
ballots
in an election
is the same concern that i have making
paper ballots available for the public
to just
open up and look through and that is it
does
uh open up uh potential for
vote buying schemes which were very
prevalent in the late 1800s before they
went to a
unique ballot there are ways that a
voter could mark a ballot so that
somebody that was interested in
buying a person's vote could
could identify that by being able to
simply review ballots cast in any given
town
and i would be i would want to be very
careful that we're not opening another
pandora's box by uh by allowing that to
happen
so with that i would be happy to answer
any questions
questions from committee members
representative prudhomme o'brien okay
it's always me um
i have these questions uh i have some
questions about the conditions of the
boxes in windham i'd like just to
i know that we went through it in the
last bill but just to reiterate for
anyone that wasn't here
there were a lot of complaints about
that in this testimony and
in your opinion
is the condition of the ballots that
came out of windham in the november 2020
general election is that a common
condition of
boxes or is that when i said ballots i
meant boxes i'm sorry
is this a common condition that that
boxes are in or is this an a very rare
condition that boxes are in in your
experience as secretary of state and
formerly a deputy
i loosely used an 80 20 percentage rate
in my testimony the last time
most towns and most town clerks
and election officials properly
prepare and seal the ballot boxes after
an election is over
but there are some
uh some towns uh that do not
do a particularly good job
and that can be seen whenever there's a
recount you know the towns that
that follow the the recommended
guidelines and procedures you know the
boxes are all uniform when they arrive
the seals are properly signed
the ones that
do not do not come in
properly
packaged are quite obvious
i think uh during the recount
and again that it's a you know it's it
is a training issue um
uh we we provide
substantial training to cities and towns
prior to an election season but the
training sessions are not mandatory
so we don't always get everyone
showing up
and there's also turnover in election
officials and so that that training is
constant and there's always a learning
curve for some
clerks
so
we need to do more work in that area
representative pimento
thank you madam chairman uh
so
you wouldn't notice these deficiencies
unless there was a recount
there's no
you wouldn't normally go out
to
every town and
check how they package the boxes that's
right we don't go out and and check as
as a matter of practice although you
know with everything that has happened
and
and the nature of the debate today as i
mentioned than the last hearing uh it
might be a good practice to start doing
checks thank you representative
representative o'brien thank you uh so a
follow-up for anyone that wasn't here
in that last uh bill that we discussed
you had mentioned
that you're going to be doing more spot
checks could you just
talk about that again correction just
because i don't want people testifying
to be put on the stand that is not what
he said what he said was that that might
be a good idea to have a conversation
about incorporating into future
practices let's not paraphrase testimony
for the benefit of other people we are
here and i to all of you to take the
testimony and respond to it as you hear
it thank you
so the question is what would a spot
check look like
we would go into a clerk's office and
simply ask to see
how the the ballots and election
materials are being stored
we would also at the same time take a
look at the logs that are associated
with
the
the ballot counting devices
so that we can make sure that those are
kept up to date and they contain proper
signatures
every time those devices are accessed
further questions from committee members
representative terezian thank you madam
chair and thank you secretary scanlon
for answering the question and i'll add
my congratulations to your new position
um
noting the concerns
i actually haven't congratulated him
because i'm suspecting that he's he may
be having second thoughts as this
proceeds so i'm leaving my words on it
on his
appointment for a future date continue
maybe the 180 day rule or something i
don't know but anyway
the concerns you noted notwithstanding
could you
support some of the added security
features
that are noted in this legislation
yes um certainly we can review the
reconciliation
procedures we do actually recommend as
part of our training uh ways that you
can reconcile
uh the ballot counts after an election
we don't cover all of the areas that
people seem to be concerned about
so you know there's certainly room for
some expansion there
and in terms of
making sure that ballots are not
counterfeit
you know there are ways to put
watermarks
you know i know of a product that is a
synthetic dna that is invisible on the
ballot
or on the paper and if you put a special
light over it it shows up i mean there
are tools like that
that uh that could be used that i don't
think would be onerous or
overly expensive
representative growing thank you madam
chair and thank you secretary scanlon
back to the high-speed scanner question
are the
milford machines that are going in are
they scanning machines as opposed to
counting machines that we currently have
the technology that is used currently is
the acuvo device which is an optical
scan
device the newer devices and the one
that will be
tested in milford is a digital scan and
so
they do have the capability of
collecting images of
on every ballot
and follow-up question on that
as far as scanning then
all the ballots regardless of of uh you
know whether they're run through current
machines or not
uh
wouldn't that be an uh like a different
type of high-speed scanner maybe similar
to what was used at the
at the audit
in in other words just adding to that
this would not be for the purpose of
counting the vote for
for the election it would be for the
purpose of recording it for
posterity and for the citizens
there
i think we're talking about maybe two
different things um the newer the newer
model ballot counting devices
using the digital scan technology can
record the images
of every ballot and so those can be
pulled up
after an election if we're talking about
an audit and using a machine
to kind of
check the counts on election night
um
there are high-speed high-speed scanners
that are capable capable of doing that i
believe they also could record images if
if they were
directed to do so
okay
and one further question one more
follow-up um
if
first of all i i agree with you on the
concern about
mailing the ballots from a vendor to the
various voting places
um
again similar to to question you were
asked if if that's changed
we could still have the same
uh authentic authentication
device in the ballots but if that were
all done through the secretary of state
and distributed from the secretary of
state would that alleviate your concern
on that
yes i mean that's the way the process is
now is that you know we
hire a vendor a printer
who works with us on preparing the
ballots
part of that process is working with
the company that that programs the
ballot counting devices so that the
timing marks and everything are
you know are properly placed on the
ballot so that the machines can read
them
and then
once the the ballot design is set the
printer prints off the amount that
we asked them to print for each town
and then
once they come off the press we have our
own staff that package them
and ship them make sure that they're
delivered to the town
thank you
thank you further questions
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
secretary
um
as i said we have a few people who have
signed up since the hearing started
i'm going to ask that their comments be
kept to three minutes
ken eyring
hello again and again thank you for the
opportunity to speak
um
yeah i just want i will be quick i want
to say that i support the
concept of bringing in security measures
on the ballots i think that's a good
idea
i agree with the secretary of state
that his office should continue to
handle the processing and the creation
of the ballots
because it is a recipe for disaster and
if you distribute that to each of the
towns you're assuming that each of those
towns assumes what their
responsibilities are and as i pointed
out in an earlier testimony that
mistakes are made
not everybody understands what their
full responsibilities are and it it
really could be a real mess for the
entire state and because
we are the first in the nation we have
to make sure that the integrity of our
elections are never questioned by
anybody outside of our state we don't
want to give them valid reasons to do
that
in section 4-3
i didn't understand the first
paragraph
it it says all ballots received shall
after inspection be stored in lock boxes
can you give us a page and i'm sorry i
think it's page
two
okay
three if you count the cover oh yeah the
bolded okay um it just says all ballots
received shall after inspection be
stored in lock boxes
and encrypted
such that only the senior election
official shall have the ability to
access the ballots
so i'm not sure what that's referring to
uh the word encrypted
uh concerned me and the the other part
that concerns me is only the senior
election official
so when you're providing
any one person without any kind of
checks and balances or
additional controls you're assuming that
that person is honorable and trustable
and not everybody is unfortunately
and you're assuming that they're
competent in their duties
and then a third question is that
if
something happens to that person
are they the only holders of the
encryption keys
so you know there would need to be
definitions as to how that if if if
things did get encrypted i don't know
what it is that would be encrypted
but you know i think there's questions
there that would have to be answered you
didn't you won't want to leave this to
the interpretation of each individual
town's election officials because that's
another disaster for
a recipe for disaster
on page 3 it says page 3 at the top
i agree that it would be helpful
for
voter integrity election integrity to
keep ballots in a locked facility with
video monitoring and logs
and lock storage containers
on page four
i welcome controls for absentee ballots
i won't get into them they're all listed
there
and then
i agree with the secretary of state i've
spent hours
talking with the secretary of state
secretary of state gardner
and secretary scanlon
was was
was in the room at the time
that some of these conversations took
place
uh and you know one of the things that i
think is
of the utmost importance and maybe one
of the most important things that the
state could do for
bringing confidence of voters
up to where it should be
for election integrity is the ability to
make ballots public documents
there are if you can finish up that
would be great okay
there there are multiple things
that need to be addressed
and i know that rep rowan has some
concerns i know that the secretary of
state he just
expressed a couple concerns about
you know the confidentiality of some
ballots that might have special markings
on them
and there's another bill for this and i
believe oh no there's not but
i'm hopeful that there will be an
amendment that will be brought up that
will address this
and have everybody's concerns addressed
because
the last conversation i had with
secretary of state gardner was that i i
think we had
um i think we had consensus on most of
these things all right if you can finish
up now so uh
so i agree with secretary
um
scanlan as well about section four
number 14 section uh or number 14. so
thank you thank you any questions from
committee members for mr eyring
i'm not seeing anything
representative
yakubovic
you signed up to speak did you want to
come up
oh sorry thank you
i don't know where what i'm on 1522 is
there a mr brendano here
welcome
if you can
we have a few minutes we're trying to do
three minutes plus whatever i gave ken
mr eyring i'll go as fast as i can okay
um first of all thank you and and for me
i'm one of those people
who uh believed always in elections i
live in kensington new hampshire it's a
small town i've been involved planning
board and other things for over 30 years
and you know i couldn't believe anything
there would be any problems and
in my town or anywhere else and so like
everything else i did my due diligence
what concerned me the most is that
the reason i'm in support of this bill
because we need to do something with
trust and transparency
and i'll give you an example
we have so many shortfalls in the
election process if we take at least
this one step it will help us and let me
outline it for you um
currently there is no chain of custody
requirements on the memory chips
or the microchips there's no chain of
custody and the sec i have a letter from
the secretary of state's office that
states that
there's no software security review or
defined specifications
there's no audit capability or defined
by the state secretary of state
there's no best practice audits by the
town clerks to review
or inspect the activity logs and those
are really important
there's no security directives updates
to the machines since august i'm sorry
april 9 2010
and there's no testing against any
controls
and what frightens me the most is this
last statement by jeffrey soristo who is
the um
head of lhs who we trust with everything
here in the town in the state
it says in on march 2021 our systems are
also subjected its lhs systems to a
post-election audit in connecticut
massachusetts vermont and a push for
those random
audits because we feel it's important to
the integrity of the system the reason
why there is no post-election audit in
new hampshire is because there's no
legislation directing one to occur a
bill is currently being considered to do
just that
so we have so many other shortfalls in
our system if we can at least start with
ballot integrity it will be a great step
for us going forward
thank you thank you any questions from
committee members
i'm not seeing any
thank you for your testimony ciao kelly
thank you madam chair i would like to
pick up uh from him what he's saying is
like in the windham audit um harry
hursty the auditor he said in europe you
automatically have an audit right after
the election
not in u.s
so um we need to have that in place and
that's one and second is
when you consider this bill and i
support this bill
is that if we need to have the machine
that can read all these new marks and
stuff like that uh let's break it up not
just all by lhs which is the one vendor
that supply all the machine in the in
new hampshire and the whole new england
they supply the machine they're testing
the machine and they maintain the
machine and they check the machine it's
like you ask one person to do the whole
thing so who doing the audit of this
work
of this machine to make sure that they
work properly and machines do make
mistake
so that is very dangerous
and
the records that we see at the windham
audit all these towns is all messed up
you know when people brought it in they
had to like
wait half an hour for them to sort
things out it's all messed up and those
high-speed machines the scanning machine
that you were talking about well in
reality we have to wait for them to run
to stables and pick up these cheapy
machines but they set up to scan that
day
the whole other set up not prepare this
is a cheap machine and standing like
like what what high-speed machine this
is a cheesy machine was it in my own
office
so i support high-speed scanning machine
high quality to store all these ballasts
it's very important
and we can still as long as we need we
don't need a lot of space for that
and
um
the uh in merrimack election there was
this one person he received a ballot is
pre-marked with a candidate that he
wouldn't support i interviewed him
so and then they didn't have enough
ballots for the day so they had to copy
more
paper ballot you know and the same thing
happened in
in um
in bedford and when i went there for the
recounts many of my friends watched the
video and said you know what child
they don't have the chance of custody
right
and it's so easy to make these copies of
these ballots so we don't even know
these boxes balance is legit
that's how much faith we have right now
in our election process so please
support this bill because this is so
important and the law needs to be
updated on these this thing because like
online crime we didn't have way back
then now we have all this technology to
track every package that you do
why not tracking our ballot i receive
absentee ballots for november election
and i didn't know i'm not supposed to
receive these things
you know otherwise i would have kept it
and bring it to the aeg and process all
these things
so who sent this ballast in
i didn't request it
thank you
thank you for your testimony does
anybody have any questions
oh by the way one more
at the windham
sorry one box in there the label is a
box it's a printing company in
california
in california
how is that that new hampshire balance
gets stored in a box from california a
printing company
that is weird that doesn't show up in
your report in the forensic audit
thank you thank you
all right that concludes the the
individuals that i have signed up to
speak on hb
1522 there were individuals who
indicated their supporter opposition to
the bill remotely by registering online
a total of
74 people supported this bill online and
three opposed thank you representative
taurosian
and we also had sign ups here today in
town
and in regards to people that did not
speak on this bill we had three people
sign up and they were all in favor of
the bill
thank you very much for your
participation on this hearing on 1522
i'm going to close
the hearing on hb 1522 and open
the hearing on hb 1527
is a bill relative to the storage of
total vote counts produced by the
electronic ballot counting devices and
the prime sponsor of the bill is with us
here today to introduce it
representative yakovovic
welcome again
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for inviting me back so
quickly
um
i'm michael yakbush of hooksett
i'm
the merrimack district 24
um
and the bill
deals with the information the
information we have um
with the
tapes that machines print
the receipts um
it's probably a simpler bill
here i'm trying to capture the
information we got and presented to the
public so these requests
um to get to the data the the receipts
of the machines
came to me from concessions from people
outside of town people in town
everywhere there was a lot of hearsay
after the election i i was actually
helping with the recount of the wyndham
election and everybody was shocked when
we saw the 400 vote discrepancies there
and then people started looking for
explanation
on their own and they didn't have much
to go by so
if they had some more data maybe they
could have helped or uncovered some and
if um i i lean towards providing
information to the people so they can
draw their own conclusions rather than
giving them something
post-processed something we interpret
because they probably will not
trust much anyway
and they do want to see the the source
so that's why i'm asking for the tapes
of the machines to be photographed
um at the at the end of the day the
moderator could do it the town clerk and
email to
the secretary of state
and
that record would be kept
on the website the isos website could be
presented to the public of each town
the original tapes would stay in the
town
and then
yeah this will provide the uniformity
basically in the eyes of the public
anybody could be able to see what the
machines counted
probably in the windham case since one
of the machines provided a lot of
overvotes that
would have been questioned right away by
members of the public so anybody who's
familiar with forensics
could identify some issues there
um so the tapes the taste would be kept
in in towns the
scans of photographs would be sent up to
the sos
office to be posted online and then
sometime later the sos could transcribe
them into a spreadsheet which is
which will show
per town how many machines were used
what the outcome
of which what the total counts of each
machine were over votes configuration of
the machine settings things like that
if they could populate this spreadsheet
the public would appreciate it too
no special specialized equipment is
needed you know the night of the
election this is all they need to take
some pictures of the tapes
that's what the deal is about
transparency
providing information to people and
let them deal with it
so we're not hiding anything thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
questions from members of the committee
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair thank you representative
um
it's really two-part question could you
explain to me what
reports for options settings sort
settings and tally settings mean
and does the accuvo tabulator generate
those kinds of reports now or can it if
it doesn't currently
thank you for the question i'm not the
top most expert into the machines but i
believe they can be configured
differently in
um different locations
so we're going after the configuration
settings of the machines
um
so we want to know the way that we're
configured
are you looking for the code that's used
to program the machines no no just the
options that are selectable
okay thank you
what's done with the overvotes
loan report short report things like
that thank you okay
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you i gotta run back to my own committee
yeah okay
also signed up to speak on this bill is
alvin c
mr c come on down
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee my name's alvin c and i'm
here speaking in favor of this bill
uh representative jakobovich did a very
good job so
there's not much more for me to say i
did want to
point out that this would be one way
that people can see
the
number of overvotes which is printed at
the top of the
battle report the tape
if the bill we discussed earlier today
goes through then this would still show
it but it would show it on the
individual
races
but overall it makes things clearer for
everybody who wants to take an interest
in this
thank you
thank you any questions for mr c
representative tarousian
i thank you madam chair thank you mr c
for taking the question i don't know if
you know not and i don't so that's why
i'm asking uh
what happens with those tapes now are
they retained at the town level does the
secretary of state get them
yeah do you know the answer
uh i don't know the complete answer i do
know that uh
the town clerk has to keep a copy but it
usually it's kept in the box sealed up
with the ballots
after the election so
if they don't have a copy and didn't
post one up on the
the wall in the
clerk's office or something like that
and there i don't know that there's a
standard on what's supposed to be done
my understanding is they're supposed to
print out three of those reports on each
machine
further questions for mr c
see none thank you very much
also signed up to speak on this bill as
ken iring
hi uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak on this bill
um
this is an important bill for voter
integrity
and election integrity
this will make it easy for people to
actually help
view the results of each town
and to see if there's any anomalies that
are taking place in any of the towns
i know they're speaking from first hand
because there were there's a group of
people
who literally went to every town to
collect the paper tapes
those paper tapes were then put into
spreadsheets and then we we
looked at the results of every machine
in every town that we acquired
it's a lot of work hundreds and hundreds
of hours just to get to the paper tapes
a lot of traveling
this bill was kind of like a sister bill
to the bill that you talked about i
believe yesterday with the voter
checklist
where
i asked where the bill asks that the
voter checklist be published
online at the secretary of state's
office because that's also a process
where you have to go to each individual
town
in order to get the checklist
hundreds of hours lots of travel
lots of wasted fuel
so
you know if if the now the paper tapes
when they come out they're stored at the
town level after the elections
it's not a big deal for
the town clerks to take images or scans
of these and then send them as a file to
the secretary of state's office that's
minimal work
but it will save citizens hundreds and
hundreds of hours
and it
it provides transparency
and again you know one of the things
that i'm most focused on is the
perception of new hampshire's elections
because we're the first in the nation
state
and questions were raised
due to
what took place in wyndham
and you know the state stepped up uh
they
you this committee passed the bill
uh you know sb43 in order to allow that
type of transparency to take place
so
uh you know this info is already
available on the 91a
so we're not asking for anything that's
not currently available
and the fact that the data would be
segregated by every machine
this ties into some of the concerns
that i expressed earlier because you'd
be able to see overvotes you'd be able
to see if machines are working properly
or not you'd have more rise on the data
to potentially point out to town
election officials that maybe there's
something they should look into
you know i don't see any drawbacks to
doing this
it's a little bit more work for the
secretary of state's office that have to
assign someone
to transcribe the data from the
from the paper tapes to
alex to the spreadsheet so they could
get posted
i did speak about this with secretary
gardner last year
he expressed a concern that they
couldn't do that within a few days the
election and my response was you know
even if it's a month
you know that would be fine you know we
just we just want to have the ability to
see the data of each of the breakdown of
each machine in each town so i i you
know i don't i haven't spoke with sec
secretary scanlan we're going to meet
tomorrow
um
i believe he was there for part of the
conversation that i had with secretary
gardner i'm hoping there's no issue
there i don't want to speak for him on
this
but all of that is uh
this is a really important bill if
if if this state is is
really
serious
about um you know
transparency and election integrity i
believe this would would help
elevate
uh you know what we're trying to do as a
state
to provide as much information to the
public as possible
the question by rep bergeron about the
the types of settings the tally settings
the sort settings
this language in here there's different
types of reports that are generated
and um
rep
yakubovic had asked me what the name of
that report is and i didn't know so i
gave him
i gave him all of the things that are
printed on the paper tape and these are
the things so you know this would
specify the report but not by name
because we didn't know what that name of
the report was
so it's it's not something that that you
know
generates more work it's just the report
that you choose when you say print
report which one and then it spits out
of the machine that's all i have thank
you very much for the time
thank you any questions from committee
members for mr eyring
thank you i'm not seeing any thank you
also signed up to speak on the on this
bill is
uh representative allegro but i'm not
sure i see him in the room
okay
um and then the last person i have
signed up to speak on this bill is ciao
kelly
ciao we're going to ask that you keep it
to about three minutes on this bill
thank you
thank you madam chair um
yes this before november
2020 election
i have complete trust and faith in our
election never worry never like concern
anything about any of this stuff so i
walked into that windham audit forensic
audit
clueless i don't understand what paper
ballot mean blank and all that stuff is
like thrown at me like crazy you watch
these things on the news but i don't
know what it is
so
this is important
this is an important thing that you know
we should put i support this bill of
course
1527 because it should be available for
the public
to trust but verify like president
reagan said
and i've been at the education
testifying to these bills that to teach
civil civil rights and information about
constitution to our children so these
should be good example so our students
our children our future leaders should
know what to look for to ensure that
they have a place in this country in the
future so they need to have real stuff
so when we walk into or we just watch
the news or just walk into the election
we know what it is we the peasants
should know what it is
not just
this professional up there
monopolize everything like lhs
monopolize everything in our elections
equipment
that is wrong so this builds it looks
small but it's important and i go to
this election they usually tape this
result on the wall someplace very we
usually take a picture and we post it on
facebook so our friends are watching it
or a live stream of people watching it
but we are just a few influences if it
goes on to the secretary of state and
the official websites of the town the
whole town should be looking out for
election integrity because the result of
this election affecting everyone
especially our pocket our heart and tax
dollars thank you so much thank you
any questions for ms kelly
i'm seeing none thanks thank you that is
the last speaker that i have signed up
to testify on
1527. there were individuals who signed
up remotely to register a position on
1527.
16 signed up in support for opposed
thank you representative terozzian and
in regards to people who did not speak
to the bill i have one person signed up
who was in favor of the bill
that concludes i with that i'm going to
close the public hearing on 1527 and
that concludes this committee's
public hearings for today and that
concludes this committee's business
today i want to thank everybody
for coming i want to thank the people
who came to testify
um and we will see you at the next
meeting thank you representative ward
has a question
um i'm going to discuss that with um
people of certain after the meeting
where i'm sort of in the middle of some
scheduling issues
one of the fun jobs of being chair
we will not have a meeting next week
um subject to
actually i should not say that um
i cuz i know i sent an email but i'm
about to have a conversation with
um
the ranking democrats members
oh you look at yeah no you're gonna
because you're in the office to clean it
up so
um to sit to see what we're gonna do so
with that we are officially done today
thank you very much everybody enjoy the
rest of your week
you